Also ich hab mir ja so ein MacBook Pro gekauft, so ein aktuelles Handy, Bildschirmprozessor und so weiter und meint es alles voll toll und dann haben ja hier meine werten Kollegen gesagt, Dennis, ohne SSD hast du die Sonne noch nicht gesehen.
Sind sie vielleicht von vorgestern?
Das kann ich ja so nie auf mir sitzen lassen.
Nein, nein.
Dann hab ich aber auch gelesen, dass die neuen MacBook Pros Probleme mit diesen SATA 3 Anschlüssen haben. Schon mit Ein-
und Ausschaltenversuch?
Intel Elmcrest 510. Und zwar haben ne Menge Leute halt schon diese Intel gekauft und sie ging einfach nicht. Teilweise Spinning Pits of Death, teilweise auch wurde die Platte nicht mal erkannt.
Okay, also der Knopf an der Seite, leuchtet der vielleicht?
Das ist einfach egal.
Sie wissen, wie ein Knopf funktioniert, oder?
Mir ist alles total egal.
Der Knopf schaltet ihn ein.
Ich starte. Und was hab ich gehört? Nix mehr. Nein, nein, die Musik hört man, wenn er angeht. Scheiß auf die Fersplatte, ich will die nicht mehr.
Ach wirklich? Wieso kommen Sie nicht einfach hier runter und machen mich fertig? Glauben Sie, ich hab Angst vor Ihnen? Ich hab keine Angst vor Ihnen.
Sie können liebend gern herkommen.
Ich werd auf Sie warten.
Wir sollten mehr über Max reden.
Herzlich willkommen bei Bumzack Return. Bumzack Bumzack Bumzack Bumzack Bumzack Bumzack Tja, so ist das, hier bei Mobile Max.
64 haben wir jetzt voll. Du bist raus.
Ich bin raus. Jetzt bin ich da.
Jetzt bist du da. Du bist die 2, nicht die 3. Das kann ja mal passieren, was?
Nein. Aber wie gut, dass ich IT-Crow nie auf Deutsch gesehen hab, oder? Und unsere Synchronen sind auch da.
War es die Deutsche?
Nee, aber auch das Englische nicht.
Das ist nicht dein Ernst, Dennis, oder?
Hatte aber schon mal.
Und hast du immer noch nicht gehört?
Ich hab auch den Anhalter noch nicht gelesen. So und zack.
Du hast den Anhalter noch nicht gelesen.
Tim schiebt die Lampe rüber, wahrscheinlich zum Good Cop, Bad Cop spielen.
Machst du dir mal selbst da. Genau.
So will ich's.
Tja, wir sind heute eingestellt auf eine extrem kurze Sendung, weil wir haben ja im Prinzip schon die Hälfte der letzten, der aktuellen Sendung der letzten gemacht.
Haben wir?
Na so gefühlt von der Menge her. Das ginge echt überhaupt nicht. Also machen wir heute hier einen Express.
Meinst du, wir können ja eigentlich hier... Die sind auch immer sehr, sehr kurz. Wann war die 24-Stunden-Grenze knacken? Oder was war das?
Ja, Dauer-Podcast. Heißt ja Live-Radio eigentlich. Aber ich glaube, 24 Stunden geht nicht. Nee, also nach 5 Stunden kippe ich um.
Also ich hätte schon gedacht, dass 4 Stunden irgendwas nicht geht, aber...
Nee, 5 Stunden ist glaube ich so das physikalische...
Also ich könnte locker 10 Stunden machen.
Wobei diese drei Vorgoden, ne? Ich hab da neulich mal nachgeschaut, nachdem wir so eine lange Sendung gemacht haben. Wir sind einfach noch nicht auch nur im Ansatz bei deren Schnitt. Geschweige denn bei deren Maximum.
Wie über was watchen die?
Ja, also ähnliche Bereiche werden da tangiert. Aber ich kann es dir nicht sagen, weil ich nicht wirklich aktiv die 6-Stunden-Sendungen durchhöre.
Also ich könnte schon noch ein paar Stunden mehr machen, aber da müsstest du ja bequemere Sitze kaufen. Du hast aber echt den Arsch weh. Das ist vielleicht Absicht.
Oder ich bringe dich mal zum Rückentraining oder so. Das kann ja auch helfen.
Nee, ist nicht mein Rücken der weh, ist mein Arsch.
Ich habe nicht gesagt, dass der weh tut, sondern der hält deinen Körper nicht richtig zusammen. Deswegen tut dein Arsch weh.
Und wo ist das Gewicht alles?
Also auf jeden Fall liegt es nicht am Stuhl. Wie auch immer. Wir wollen ja hier mehr über Max reden. Ja, und es gibt auch gute Gründe dafür, das zu tun.
Du wolltest jetzt bloß noch mal einen sauberen Aufnahmethode von diesem... Damit beim nächsten Mal einen sauberen Schnitt hat von wir müssen mal wieder über Max reden. Nur darum hast du das gesagt, oder?
Ich bin so durchschaubar, oder?
Ja, wir wollten eigentlich über die Location Gate reden, aber jetzt haben wir uns entschieden, dass wir doch noch ein bisschen vom weißen iPhone berichten.
Foto, Foto, wir hatten hier letztes oder vorletztes Mal haben wir schon ein Foto gemacht. Sieht immer noch genauso aus. Der Chat, der ist einfach, ich weiß nicht, Leute, das geht so nicht.
Okl ist nicht da, der muss arbeiten.
Ja, Leute, Leute, Leute wollen auch richtig chatten hier und so. Da kann man nicht gestern nach Fotos schreien.
Bisschen mehr Disziplin.
Reist euch mal zusammen. Also, Macs, Komma, Neue gibt's seit gestern, nämlich neue iMacs. Und das find ich gut. Eigentlich hat es noch nicht Kaufreiz induziert. Also keinen unmittelbaren Kaufreiz. Aber ich hab ja schon so ein Ding. Weil ich glaub, wenn ich noch nicht so ein Teil hätte, dann würd ich mir sofort eins kaufen.
Und zwar über den Affiliate-Link auf unserer Seite.
Da gibt's keinen zum Mac kaufen. Oder gibt's das auch bei Amazon? Ich weiß nicht. Ja, dieser Apple Store, das ist ganz interessant. Ich hab ja irgendwie mich mal bemüht, da auch so einen Affiliate-Link für den Apple Store zu bekommen. Und nachdem sie mich da irgendwie einmal abgelehnt haben, es ja nochmal probiert haben, schicken sie ja neulich so eine freche Mail mit, ach ja, übrigens, wir nehmen jetzt überhaupt gar keine mehr. Wir haben irgendwie genug finden. Es gibt dafür jetzt keine neuen Werbepartner. Die, die jetzt irgendwie bisher dabei waren, die dürfen wohl auch dabei bleiben, aber ja, ich find's jetzt gerade mal einfach nicht so interessant.
Dann kann ich meinen Double-Click-Account hier meist bieten, versteigern, irgendwo?
Double-Click?
War das nicht Double-Click?
Trade-Doubler. Weiß nicht, aber in Trade-Doubler kann man ja noch andere Dinge tun, gibt's ja auch immer noch den iTunes Store zum Beispiel.
Ja, aber ich hab da ja noch so ein FFD-Programm gelobt, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht. Nee, nee, Quatsch, für iTunes natürlich nur.
Jaja, für iTunes kriegt jeder. Aber für Apple Store, da sind sie ja irgendwie so ein bisschen zickig, keine Ahnung warum.
Picky.
Naja, wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall gibt's neue IMAX und die Neuigkeiten sind eigentlich schnell zusammengefasst. Stimmt's?
DARS?
Hast du mal hingeguckt?
In die IMAX? Alles gleich, Sandy Bridge und Double Thunderbolt bei dem Decken.
Schön zusammengefasst.
Double Thunderbolt.
Ja, bei dem Decken aber nur.
Und ist ein bisschen billiger geworden.
50 Euro der kleine, 75 der große oder 100 oder irgendwie so.
Genau, also man spart sich so ein bisschen was, aber ist glaube ich im Wesentlichen nur so ein, ja weiß ich auch nicht woran das liegt, vielleicht sind die superschnellen Prozessoren jetzt nicht mehr so teuer oder so. Aber das mit dem Thunderbolt, es gibt ja diese, ich meine erst mal hast du zwei Thunderbolts und was jetzt wohl geht, ist, dass du sogar zwei externe Bildschirme anschließen kannst. So ein kleines Video gesehen, aber in Gadget. Und ich muss sagen, also...
Not too shabby.
Nein, das kann schon echt überzeugen. Also wenn ihr noch so zwei 27 oder 30 Zoll Bildschirme leisten kannst.
Für die gesparten 75 Euro kann man sich da alles von holen.
Nachteil ist, man kann nur noch Rechner mit Thunderbolt-Schnittstelle. Können nur noch den iMac als Display benutzen.
Genau, das habe ich ehrlich gesagt noch nicht so richtig verstanden, warum das eigentlich so sein muss. Hast du das begriffen? Also ich meine, warum ist das so? Meinem Verständnis nach ist ja Thunderbolt der Display-Teil ist ja Mini DisplayPort kompatibel. Das war ja von Anfang an die Aussage. Warum kann sich jetzt dieser Rechner gegenüber einem anderen Rechner, der auch nur DisplayPort kennt, nicht, also warum kann er nicht in so einen DisplayPort-Only-Modus umschalten? Das verstehe ich irgendwie nicht so richtig.
Damit zusammen, mal sehen, ob ich jetzt gerade totalen Bullshit erzähle. Das ist jetzt reine Rumpf-Fantasiererei, aber vielleicht die Ausgangsport fürs Display. Haben die eine Reihenfolge, eine Richtung, in die so ein DisplayPort-Kabel rein muss? Weißt du das?
Was meinst du mit Reihenfolge?
Na ja, jedes DisplayPort-Kabelende in beide Seiten, das ist komplett wurscht.
Das Kabel hat keine Richtung.
Die Stecker sind auch immer dieselben. Weißt du, wie die gepolt sind?
Nein, das kann ja nicht der Grund sein, weil das ist ja bei Thunderbolt genauso.
Das ist ja derselbe Stecker.
Vielleicht haben sie Kabel, die bisher für das Eingangssignal zuständig waren, die für Thunderbolt mitgenutzt. Obwohl, das kann eigentlich nicht sein.
Vielleicht sprechen sie als Thunderbolt darüber.
Braucht Thunderbolt eigentlich neue Kabel?
Na klar, sprechen sie Thunderbolt darüber.
Aber nicht mehr Mini DisplayPort.
Doch, du musst ja weiterhin Mini DisplayPort.
Vielleicht checken sie ihr Bildsignal über Thunderbolt und nicht über Mini DisplayPort.
Na ja, ganz offensichtlich ist es so, dass sie auf der anderen Seite einen Rechner erwarten, der Thunderbolt-aware ist und das hat. Und eben nicht nur DisplayPort. Das ist ja klar. Ich frage jetzt, warum? Welche große technologische Hürde hat sie davon abgehalten, diesen Bildschirmport auch in einem DisplayPort-Only-Modus zu betreiben?
Technologische Hürde brauchen die keine. Die wollen einfach nur neue Geräte verschopfen.
Wieso? Das ist einfach Quatsch. Weil jetzt irgendwie kann man sich den... Also wenn ich mir jetzt diesen iMac kaufe, und das Argument für mich ist, kann ich auch als externen Bildschirm benutzen. Ich habe aber irgendwie jetzt noch zwei Jahre lang Geräte rumstehen, die haben halt nur Displayport, dann geht das halt nicht. Das heißt, da fällt ein Kaufeinreiz weg. Warum sollten sie das Feature überhaupt erst reinbauen, wenn es kein Kaufeinreiz darstellt? Ach, das ist immer so diese typische These, dass sie das nur machen, um einen zum Upgrade zu zwingen. Das ist nie... Genau. Die sind total evil. Genau. Ich verstehe es nicht. Also sicherlich hat sie wieder irgendeinen Einspargrund und selbst wenn sich da nur Software, Firmware oder was auch immer einsparen, aber dass das jetzt zwingend so sein muss, des womenigen Cop.
Also bei dir ist es so, da kann man normal, man hat den Mini Display Port ausgehangen, du hast den Mini Display Port Eingang oder wie und dann kann ich deinen Bildschirm bei mir benutzen. Auch wenn ich Thunderbolt gerade bei meinem MacBook Pro habe.
Das wär... Ja, das muss ja gehen, weil du musst ja auch mit dem Port normal Display Port antreiben können, also so ein Display Port Client in dem Sinne muss das Ding ja können. Das probieren wir jetzt übrigens nicht aus, weil sonst ist der Stream wieder weg. Das Problem ist ja immer noch ungelöst, auch wenn ich gehört habe, dass mein Bugreport mittlerweile zumindest die erste Hürde genommen hat bei Apple.
Wie, was heißt das?
Ich hab den mal in ausführlichem Bugreport zu diesem Umschalter-Bug beschrieben.
Und was ist die erste Hürde?
Die ist nicht gelöscht worden.
Ich kann da jetzt nicht so im Detail drauf eingehen, aber ich hab Erkenntnisse, dass das Problem mehr als nur von einer Software zur Kenntnis genommen wurde.
Ich fahr dran.
People are looking at it. Das heißt gar nichts am Ende, aber wie auch immer. Ich finde auf jeden Fall die neuen iMacs toll. Das Einzige, was mich ein bisschen enttäuscht hat, bzw. ich hatte jetzt keine wirkliche Erwartung, ich hatte nur so eine Hoffnung, dass sie einen Bold Move machen, was so diese SSD-Geschichte betrifft. Genau. Weil das sieht ja irgendwie so aus, als ob sie nach wie vor da einfach so 2,5 Zoll SSDs reinbauen.
Achso, du meinst, dass sie M-Sata verbauen oder sowas?
Genau, dass sie da einfach genauso wie in ihrem Air ihre Modülchen reinstecken. Vielleicht tun sie das auch, aber ich hatte so nicht den Eindruck, weil das Upgrade, das Pricing, na gut, am Ende ist das ja auch nicht entscheidend, wie das gepackagt ist. Vielleicht ist es so, das werden wir sehen. Aber ich hätte mir halt gewünscht, dass sie das irgendwie billiger machen. Und zwar eh klart handbilliger. Es ist billiger, aber es ist glaube ich nur so, Spaß irgendwie so 75 Euro bei der 256 GB Option von SSD. Naja, sodass also meine hätte ich gerne Konfiguration mir dann doch so ein bisschen zu teuer ist erstmal. Mal schauen. Also sobald ich hier den Urge spüre, vielleicht auf ein zweites Gerät zu gehen oder dringend ein Upgrade machen muss, dann vielleicht. Aber das sind auf jeden Fall schöne Maschinen. Das stimmt. Also finde ich wirklich ordentlich.
Mir ist nie aufgefallen, dass die nur ein i3 vorher drin hatten.
Klein.
Ja, jetzt sind sie total auf i5, glaube ich.
Wenn mich nicht alles teuer.
Doch, die hatten die ganze Zeit immer nur i5 verwendet.
Ne, du musstest das Top-Modell kaufen, um Quad-Core zu haben. Und dann kotzt du da noch auf die i7 Option mit diesem 4 plus Hyper-Threading, acht virtuelle Codes.
Die gibt es jetzt nicht mehr, Isa.
Doch, die gibt es immer noch, weil alles ist i5. Und du kannst halt dann noch auf i7 gehen, aber auch das geht, glaube ich, nur bei dem 27 Zoll Gerät.
Ich dachte, da wäre eine Option rausgeflogen, weil die noch nicht Sandy Bridge tauglich ist.
Was ist nicht Sandy Bridge tauglich?
Ich weiß es nicht mehr. Ich gucke mal kurz und dann brüll ich einfach, wenn ihr beim nächsten Thema seid.
Oh Gott, du brüllst. Kann man ja mal schnell hinterherklicken hier. Ist ja alles gar nicht so schwierig. Wir haben ja auch die Webseite so ein bisschen verändert.
Mensch, Kinder, die machen jetzt echt viel von diesem HTM L5.
Was ist das denn für ein cooler Effekt?
Es flutscht und...
Wie ich jetzt so die iMacs aufbaue, wenn man mit dem Finger über das iPad drüber geht?
Oh, ist ja auch schick. Ach, die Webseite ist jetzt sogar touch aware.
Ja, gibst du das auf der...
Ist das auf der Homepage?
Nee, das ist jetzt auf der iMac-Seite.
Ich will auch touch haben.
Musst du dir ein iPad holen?
Ja.
Mach ich auch.
Da ist ein iPad hier, kannst du benutzen.
Das ist ein echt schöner Effekt.
Das geht nur mit touch, das geht nicht mit der Maus.
Das geht nicht mit der Maus?
Nein, das geht nicht mit der Maus.
Das geht auch, sollte ich mal ein Video von machen hier, ne?
Also du kannst nur klicken und dann passiert das, automatisch, aber dass du so richtig so draggen kannst, das nicht. Ja, mach das mal mit Flash. Wir müssen nochmal ein paar Webseiten beschimpfen, die noch Flash benutzen nachher.
Meine Taste geht nicht.
Ja, ist bestimmt mit Flash.
Was, deine Stummschaltungstaste?
Zum Beispiel. Das geht grundsätzlich nicht.
Ach so, das, äh, ach Flash geht nicht.
Ja, du hast Flash gesagt. Das stimmt. Ich muss mich entschuldigen, aber dann müsst ihr mal kurz das Thema bestimmen, dann können wir da dran arbeiten.
Nee, die haben alle einen Core i5. Durch die Bank weg.
Hab ich keinen Core i7?
Achso, da gibt es noch optional 3,4 GHz, nur im Apple Store erhältlich. Sowohl für die 21, äh, für die...
Genau, also ok, also auch das große kleine iMac als auch der große große iMac kann das. Und dann halt gleich 3,4 GHz. Also das ist schon, schon eine Menge Hub in dem System, ne? Mit 2,8 GHz i7 hab ich.
Menschenskinder. Geht ja noch mehr.
Ja, aber es macht keinen Sinn ohne SSD. Es ist einfach Quatsch. Also wer jetzt darüber nachdenkt, sich einen iMac zu kaufen und nicht auch darüber nachdenkt, sich eine SSD zu kaufen, der kann auch mit der kleinsten Prozessorkonfiguration klarkommen. Es sei denn, er hat jetzt so erst den ganzen Tag nur am DVD-Rippen. Ich glaub, DVD-Rippen ist wahrscheinlich das einzige, wo man überhaupt die CPU nutzt, oder?
Nee, auch nicht mehr, oder?
Wie?
Blu-ray-Rippen?
700 Pixel, was willst du da lange Rippen? Sondern null Komma nüscht fertig. Quad-Core, das ist doch...
Na ja, gut, aber wenn du haltest.
Das langsamste am DVD-Rippen ist, die DVD einlesen. Das heißt, du musst einfach... Also, ich glaub mir, die sind nicht mal mehr auf 100 Prozent, wahrscheinlich die CPUs beim DVD-Rippen. Also nicht, wenn man ein 4 hat.
Na doch, die CPUs sollten schon auf 100 Prozent sein.
Nein, weil die DVD kann ich so schnell einladen.
Ach so, jetzt weiß ich, was du meinst.
Glaub ich.
Also bei mir ist das nicht so. Ich hab hier schon alle 8 Chores voll und da Volllast. Ja, but we're getting there. Und es ist wirklich beunruhigend. Also der Schritt zur SSD ist dieses Jahr noch nicht vollständig vollzogen worden. So nicht mit den Macbook Pros, genau, nicht mit diesen iMacs. Aber es ist schon mal gut, dass es das so als Option gibt. Ich denke, wir sind auch noch ganz schön weit davon entfernt, dass wir so zwei Terabyte SSD kriegen.
Da muss man noch eine Weile warten.
Und grundsätzlich finde ich das jetzt auch gar nicht so eine schlechte Idee, dass es eine interne SSD gibt und dann nochmal eine interne HD dazu, weil HD einfach schön billig ist für viel Platz noch. Aber es muss halt einfach, es muss halt einfach, es muss halt einfach, es muss halt einfach passieren.
Das ist einfach so krass, der Unterschied.
Na ja, gut, wir wiederholen uns. Ja, und ist sonst noch irgendwas passiert in den letzten zwei Wochen?
Ich hab irgendwas gehört.
Ihr auch?
Weißes iPhone, ne?
Weißes iPhone, genau.
Stimmt, wir haben weiße iPhones.
Wir können ja ein bisschen über Location Gate reden.
Nee, lass uns erstmal das weiße iPhone.
Weil ich hab nämlich gehört, Osama bin Laden, hat nämlich sein iPhone benutzt und...
Da hatten sie ihn.
Weiß der Osama bin Laden, hat ein weißes iPhone gehabt?
Klar.
Der hat ja auch mal so weißes Tuch an und so.
Ich fand übrigens bei Not Safe For Work, die Sendung, die hör ich mir nur, also ich weiß nicht, ob ich sie mir wirklich anhöre, aber den Titel fand ich grandios.
Osama died for your sins?
Ich weiß nicht, wie das entstanden ist, aber ich kann es mir...
Im Vorfeld schon, das war zu naheliegend. Okay, also gehen wir nochmal das Thema an hier. Location Gate, die letzten zwei Wochen. Irgendwie kam dieses ganze Ding überhaupt erst so richtig an den Tag, wo wir die Sendung gemacht haben. Genau, und dann haben wir uns alle noch so ein bisschen gewundert. Und dann war das mit diesem iPhone-Trecker da. Und den hab ich ja hier auch mal gestartet. Und ich hab ja auch mal ihn auf mein Telefon gucken lassen. Und dann war ich ganz begeistert, dass das ja alles so aussah, als ob. Und tatsächlich war es auch so, dass eben die dort vorhandenen von diesem iPhone-Trecker ausgewerteten Daten, zumindest auf meinem Telefon, schon Orte benannte, an denen ich war. Na ja, es war halt auf den ersten Blick, waren das alles so Regionen, wo ich mich aufgehalten hab. Das waren so die Bahnstrecken, die ich fuhr, Urlaubsort, Berlin und so. Dann kamen ja noch irgendwie ein paar andere Tools raus. Heise hat irgendwie so einen My-Phone-Trecker rausgebracht. Das war etwas merkwürdig, der Output davon, aber da war dann irgendwie, also ich weiß nicht, ob das Ding fehlerhaft war oder ob das nur war, hast du das auch mal ausprobiert?
Ich hab da irgendwie noch so ein zweites Tool ausprobiert, aber irgendwie hatte das auch keine Timeline und nix und hat alles so ganz komisch auf Google Maps dargestellt. Das habe ich auch nicht geblickt. Wo irgendwie so Zahlen waren, wie oft man dort irgendwie war. Es war so...
Keine Ahnung, ich hab's auch nur eine Weile ausprobiert und bin irgendwie nicht so richtig schlau geworden aus den Ergebnissen und hatte dann auch schon wieder was anderes zu tun. Also dessen habe ich mich nicht so richtig angenommen. Naja, auf jeden Fall kursierten ja dann verschiedene Verschwörungstheorien darüber, was denn nun Apple eigentlich tatsächlich getan hätte. Was sind so die schönsten, die ihr so gehört habt? Also generell war ja Apple extrem böse.
Also ich find's immer super, dass das immer sofort für Werbung ist. Die legende Cash-Natei auf deiner Festplatte, auf deinem iPhone, ja, das ist nur für Werbung. Für Werbung? Ja, weil für Werbung ist ja Werbung. Hast du jemals einen Shampoo-Verkäufer erlebt, der dir einen Shampoo verkaufen wollte, ohne dass er vorher deine Position erfahren hat? Siehste, in der Werbeindustrie ist Location das A und O.
Wo hast du das gelesen?
Und die Internet!
Und die Internet. Ich weiß nicht, dein Supermarkt fragt dich auch nach deiner Postleitzahl manchmal.
Stimmt.
Das tun die auch deswegen.
Ja, natürlich sind Location-Daten für Werbung durchaus interessant. Aber jetzt eine Datei, die auf einem eigenen Gerät liegt und nicht übertragen wird, was die jetzt für die Wärmeindustrie besonders interessant sein soll, erschließt sich mir nicht nur so halb. Aber es ist immer so ein schönes Dauerargument.
Ich fasse auf jeden Fall erstaunlich, wie schnell sich alle einig waren. Die Daten waren eigentlich noch nicht im Ansatz verstanden. Schon kräten sie auf allen Kanälen. Und der Tenor war im Wesentlichen so, das iPhone weiß immer wo du bist, speichert das, Apple weiß immer wo du bist. Allerdings gibt es meiner Meinung nach bisher noch keinerlei Erkenntnisse darüber, dass das Telefon tatsächlich deine Position im Sinne von identifizierter Position regelmäßig oder unregelmäßig an Apple weitergeleitet hat.
Es wurde aber vorher schon bekannt, dass es alle 12 Stunden stattfindet.
Das was alles 12 Stunden stattfindet?
Dass Apple die Positionen hochschickt.
Die Positionen oder die Positionen nennen?
Die Position nennen.
Welche Position nennen?
Also das iPhone, also Apple hat ja dieses Skyhawk Wireless gekündigt. Die haben jetzt ihre eigene Datenbank. Um die aufzubauen, braucht man ja irgendwie das Wissen, wo welche Basisstation ist und wie stark du die empfängst, weil du stehst ja nicht direkt da, wo die Basisstation ist, sondern die Basisstation ist irgendwo, schätzen die halt so, keine Ahnung, 200 Meter von dir oder die Signalstärke schätzen die halt ein und dazu brauchen sie erstmal aber die Position des iPhones. Und wenn du dann fünf Stationen siehst mit unterschiedlichen Empfangsstärken, dann schicken die das in ihre Datenbank und speichern an der Position, kann man diese Basisstation mit folgenden Empfangsstärken sehen. Und wenn dann irgendein Tag später einer genau an einem bestimmten Punkt auf dieser Welt steht, wo er genau diese fünf Stationen mit den Empfangsstärken sieht, dann denken die, rechnen die aus, alles klar, dann muss der ja wohl auch an dieser Position sein. So, und damit die diese Datenbank aufbauen können, hat auch Stand bei FSC Karlock irgendwie, der hat sich nämlich auch aufgeregt, warum nicht alle vor einem halben Jahr schon rumgeheult haben, weil da war das nämlich auch schon bekannt. Dazu schickt halt Apple wohl alle zwölf Stunden diese Daten zu Apple, damit wir diese Datenbank bauen können.
Also die Updates sozusagen. Aber wenn ich die ganze Debatte jetzt richtig verstanden habe, ist es so, es ist nicht so, dass permanent, also wenn sich nichts ändert an dem Datensatz, den du in diesem Cache hast, also wenn deine Bewegung keine neuen Erkenntnisse erzielt, dann werden da auch keine Aktualisierungen vorgenommen.
Also der Timestamp wird aktualisiert. Wird er? Der wird zumindest, ich weiß nicht nach welchem Prinzip, aber der ist, also was mir aufgefallen ist, als ich unterwegs war mit dem, oder als ich mir meine Daten damit angeguckt habe, dass ich hab mir den Quellcode mal runtergeladen von diesem, wie heißt das, iPhone Tracker von diesem App und hab mal die Präzision ein bisschen erhöht. Die haben immer gesagt, dass sie die Präzision runtergesetzt haben und dann hab ich eben die zwei Konstanten ein bisschen finer gemacht, die da drinstehen, an denen die Präzision definiert wird, sodass ich nicht mehr nur noch im Wochenrhythmus sehen konnte, sondern auch im Tagesrhythmus was passiert ist und eben die Lokalisierung ein bisschen genauer war, beziehungsweise die Masken mir etwas genauer angezeigt worden sind. Dabei ist mir aufgefallen, dass ich an extrem vielen, also an Orten, an denen ich mich häufiger aufhalte, da hat er keine Daten gehabt. Und ich vermute, dass, also entweder er schreibt es rein, aber ich glaube, das ist tatsächlich so, wann er das letzte Mal den gesehen hat, den Punkt, dass das angezeigt wird. Also sozusagen, wenn du jetzt, wenn du vorhast, einen Mord zu begehen und dann gehst du einfach an dem Tag hin, an dem du den Mord begonnen hast und am nächsten Tag nochmal und dann hast du die Daten vom zweiten Tag dastehen.
Also man sieht sozusagen, der Datenbank, also diese Datenbank, also Datenbank ist ja gut, also dieses, ja, es ist eine Datenbank, die als Cache definiert wird, zu Recht in gewisser Hinsicht. Und wenn du an einem Ort zweimal warst, dann ist dieser Ort nach wie vor nur einmal drin. Das ist natürlich die Frage, was ist so ein Ort? Ist es irgendwie zehn Meter weiter schon ein anderer Ort?
Das kann man ja auch einfach erklären.
Das sind ja die Sendemasten, die da drinnen stehen.
Genau, also pass mal auf, Steve hat ja gesagt, ich will jetzt mal den zu Hilfe nehmen, nicht dass das alles absegende, was Steve sagt, ist irgendwie heilig, aber so hat er es erklärt und dann macht es vielleicht auch Sinn oder auch nicht, muss jeder selber wissen. Aber er hat gesagt, die Daten sind ja gar nicht die Position des Users, sondern, also das wird nie gespeichert, die Position des Users, sondern was die da speichern, sind die Stationen, die das iPhone halt in der Nähe sieht. Der hat ja auch erklärt, deswegen können auch Stationen drin sein, die 100 Meilen weit weg sind, weil wenn die nächste Station, wenn da keiner ist, wo du gerade bist und die nächste ist halt 100 Meilen weit weg, dann speichern die halt diese. Damit sie in deinem Umfeld, wo du gerade bist, alle Basis-Stationen irgendwie in diesem Cache haben, damit wenn du irgendwie keinen GPS mehr hast oder in einem Haus bist, dass du dann trotzdem anhand der Basis-Stationen, dass sie dann trotzdem wissen, wo du ungefähr bist. So gesehen stimmt das schon, die speichern gar nicht deine Position, sondern die speichern die Position der in der Nähe befindlichen Stationen. Also WLAN oder Zeltowers haben sie ja eh. Und die könnten natürlich jetzt irgendwie die ganze Datenbank, die die da bei Apple rumliegen haben, also die ganze Welt auf dein iPhone schieben, macht ja aber keinen Sinn, weil du brauchst dann nur die aus deiner Nähe, weil sonst wär's ja ein bisschen sehr groß. Weiß ja nicht, wie groß die Datenbank bei denen da ist.
Aber sie haben ja nicht die Position der Zeltowers. Sie haben ja nur die Information, dass sie einen Zeltower sehen an einer bestimmten Position.
Nein, nein, bei Apple haben sie doch Stationen und ihre ungefähre Location. Und die schieben sie halt aufs iPhone mit der Umgebung, wo du bist und mit einem Zeitstempel von wann diese Information ist. Und das ist eigentlich das, was die da machen. Das heißt, wenn ich hier durch die Straße laufe, dann kriege ich anscheinend auch auf mein iPhone, raufgespielt von Apple, die ganzen Stationen, die hier in der Nähe sind. Damit, wenn ich hier langlaufe und gerade irgendwie im GPS-Windschatten bin, trotzdem irgendwie rausfinden kann, alles klar, ich bin ungefähr hier so. Wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe. Und dann macht auch der Satz Sinn, wenn Steve sagt, das ist gar nicht die Position des Users, sondern es ist nur der Cash von der Station in der Nähe des Users.
Na gut, aber es bezieht sich ja auch auf WLAN-Basestationen. Und die WLAN-Basestationen kennen sie die Position nicht.
Sondern?
Na, die wissen ja nicht, wo eine Base Station steht. Sie wissen nur, wo sie sie sehen. Wenn ich auf der Straße stehe, dann sehe ich vielleicht 30 Base Stations. Und da sind ein paar vielleicht in unmittelbarer Nähe, aber ein paar sind halt auch 50, 60 Meter weg.
Ja, aber da können die doch ausrechnen, wo so eine Station ist. Genau.
Wir können auch einfach in dem... Also in einer Station...
Also in einer links von so einer Station ist und einer rechts und einer im Norden und einer im Süden. Da können die langsam ausrechnen, wo diese Welt ist.
Ja, ja, ja. Aber das rechnet ja nicht mein Telefon aus. Das heißt, um eine Information über diese Basestation abzuspeichern, kann er eigentlich erstmal nur sagen, ich bin jetzt gerade hier, meine Position und von hier aus sehe ich das, diese Information. Das geht dann nach oben zu Apple. Und daraus können sie dann, indem sie mehrere Positionen von dir und anderen iPhones zusammennehmen, sagen, ah, da man jetzt diese Basestation an diesen 30 Orten gesehen hat, muss das wahrscheinlich irgendwo dazwischen liegen und das definieren wir jetzt mal als diesen Ort. Und dann erst kann diese Information zurückfließen in dein Telefon, sodass in deinem Cash auch tatsächlich drin steht, hier ist eine WLAN-Basestation vermutlich an diesem Ort. Und das kannst du jetzt auch als Basis nehmen. Aber wenn ich halt rumlaufe und irgendwas anderes sehe oder irgendwas sich geändert hat, dann muss das Telefon ja zwangsläufig die eigene Position nehmen als Hint, um dann später ausrechnen zu können, wo die wahrscheinlich wirklich steht. Also es ist schon irgendwie nicht so, dass die festgestellte Ist-Position des iPhones nicht geschickt wird, aber sie wird eben laut Apple anonymisiert geschickt. Das kann man glaube ich auch einfach so kaufen.
Ja, wobei...
Bis das Gegenteil bewiesen ist.
Das hat, ich habe gestern schon in einem anderen Podcast über das selbe Thema geredet, weil wir müssen reden. Und da kam dann der Einwand, naja, aber Location-Daten sind nur sehr, sehr schwer zu anonymisieren. Weil, wenn ich jeden Morgen ungefähr hier in der Straße dahinten bin und dann morgens dahin fahre, dann hat man schon zwei sehr, sehr eindeutige Punkte, die vermutlich nur auf mich zutreffen, nämlich wo wohne ich, wo arbeite ich. Und das ist schon ein relativ eindeutiges Merkmal. Das heißt, selbst wenn man diese Daten anonymisiert und sie einem Gerät zuordnen kann und jetzt die Polizei ankommt und sich fragt, welcher von denen war jetzt Max, dann können die mich relativ leicht aus den Daten rausfiltern.
Ja, wenn man es einem Gerät zuordnen kann. Du meinst, zuordnen kann auf Basis dieser Daten oder zuordnen kann, weil es eine Zuordnung hat zu einem Gerät. Weil die Aussage steht ja, dass eigentlich die User ID, also weder die Identität des Owners noch die...
Du meinst, das ist nicht mal die...
Jaja, die Identität des Telefons wird dort nicht mit übertragen.
Nicht mal die. Also sozusagen, dass wirklich nur noch...
Kann man nur glauben, weil es verschlüsselte Kommunikation ist. Ich hab's nicht getraced, keine Ahnung.
Ich auch nicht.
Aber so steht die Aussage im Raum von Apple.
Ja, dann hätten sie nur einzelne Datenpunkte, sozusagen.
Also ich bin mir sicher, dass wenn man jetzt viele anonyme Tracks nimmt und darüber in Großkorrelationen fährt, dass man dann auch noch was rauskriegen könnte und zuordnen könnte. Gar keine Frage. Aber das ist eben nicht die Information, an der sie an der Stelle interessiert sind, sondern sie sind einfach daran interessiert, dieses Netzwerk aufzubauen. Und das halte ich ja auch für ein absolut wünschenswertes Feature. Und das wäre ja auch schön doof, wenn man die ohnehin nicht durch die gegen laufenden Telefone auch als Datensammler heranzieht. Aber da sind natürlich Probleme mit drin. Was halt jetzt wirklich blöd war, und das haben sie ja auch offensichtlich dann auch eingesehen ist, erst mal waren halt noch Einträge in dieser Datenbank, die sehr alt war. Also die sehr alte Timestamps.
Ich nehme an, da war die Person nie wieder gewesen und deswegen wurden die nicht geupdatet.
Genau, und dann lagen sie aber da rum und wurden da nicht rausgepurgt. Und wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, war der technische Grund der, dass sie sich gesagt haben, wir machen jetzt hier mal zwei, was war das, zwei Megabyte Cash-Größe, passt schon.
Waren zwei Megabyte?
Ich hab zwei Megabyte im Ohr, dass du das gesagt hast in dem Interview. Und nun sind das ja keine riesigen Daten, da ist zwei MB schon wirklich viel.
Ich glaube, meine war deutlich größer als zwei Megabyte, darum.
Da stand da, dass sie es vorhat mit zwei MB, aber dann irgendwie anders gemacht haben.
Ich glaube nämlich, dass das so bei mir so um 40, 50 Megabyte Bereich war.
Das ist aber jetzt auch alles so ein bisschen History, weil, wie wir ja gerade hier gehört haben, ist natürlich klar, dass wenn wir einen Podcast machen, da kann sich Apple das nicht erlauben, da nicht schnell ein Update rauszubringen, logisch.
Genau, das Update ist wohl draußen. Ja, aber okay, zwei MB, vergessen wir das, wie auch immer. Sie haben diese alten Sachen nicht rausgelöscht. Ob sie von vornherein keinerlei Löschfunktionen vorgesehen hatten oder ob sie eine drin hatten, die aber nicht funktioniert hat, wurde so direkt nicht gesagt. Sie sprachen aber auf jeden Fall von einem Bug. Der ist ja offensichtlich der andere Bug, den sie jetzt wohl auch behoben haben werden mit dem Update. Das war zumindest die Ankündigung, dass sie auch diesen Cache nicht mehr back-upen.
Dass es gar nicht mehr mit dem Backup landet, dass es sozusagen auf dem MacBook Pro, weil da gibt es ja nur dieses iPhone-Tracker, dass es gar nicht mehr da rankommt.
Genau, das heißt, diese Datei verlässt das Gerät dann auch erst mal gar nicht. Zumindest nicht in dem normalen Prozess.
Und zusätzlich, dass wenn man jetzt dieses Lokalisieren auf dem iPhone ausschaltet, dass diese Datei auch erst mal gelöscht wird und man danach mit einer frischen anfängt.
Die Datei wirklich gelöscht wird oder? Oder einfach nicht weitergeschrieben wird?
Sie wird nicht vorgehalten und sie laden dann auch keine Updates runter. Also, das ist ja zum Beispiel eine relativ neue Information, die dieser ganzen Sache noch mit rauskam. Dass das Telefon eben tatsächlich permanent Teile einer zentral errechneten Datenbank herunterlädt für diese Lokalisierung. Man hat immer gesagt, okay, die Lokalisierung findet statt, aber wie sie genau funktioniert, ist ja so nie beschrieben worden.
Na ja, aber dass dafür Daten irgendwo runtergeladen werden mussten, war ja klar, oder?
Ja, aber trotzdem ist nicht beschrieben worden, wie es genau funktioniert. Das ist ja jetzt eigentlich rausgekommen bei dieser ganzen Geschichte. Hätten sie es beschrieben, wie es rauskommt, dann wäre sicherlich auch der ganze Fu in den Medien nicht so groß gewesen.
Oh, da hab ich heftige Zweifel dran.
Nicht so groß gewesen. Es hätte auf jeden Fall eine realistische Chance bestanden, dass das von vornherein anders kommentiert worden ist. Aber es ist sicher gleich alle so dermaßen verstiegen, bis hin zu Geheimdienst-Verschwörungstheorien, dass die Geheimdienste Apple zwingen, diese Daten vorzuhalten, was natürlich im Lichte der realen Erkenntnisse Quatsch ist. Ich meine, kann ja sein, dass das iPhone tatsächlich diese Information noch irgendwo vorhält, aber dass die Datei auch jetzt schon nicht gebackupt wird und unverschlüsselt ist und bisher noch keiner gefunden hat, weil da nur irgendwie Binärmüll drinsteht. Kann ja sein. Kann man nicht ausschließen.
Glaube ich aber nicht.
Solange bis das Gegenteil bewiesen wurde.
Oder glaubst du das?
Glaubst du, dass die Geheimdienste hinter uns her sind? Klar. Uns iPhone-Usern?
Also ich glaube sehr wohl natürlich. Also nicht uns iPhone-Usern, aber dass die generell mit jedem größeren Hersteller im Gespräch sind und mal gucken, was man da irgendwie reinkriegen kann in das Gerät. Das glaube ich schon.
Echt?
Ja.
Also ich denke, wenn man Apple kauft, dann ist man einfach vom Terrorismus-Verdacht befreit.
Ach so, weil Bin Laden ja ein weißes iPhone hatte?
Ne, Bin Laden hat kein weißes iPhone. Er hat ein Stimm-Windows benutzt und jetzt hat er seine gerechte Strafe dafür bekommen.
You infidels will use Windows Phone 7 too.
Oder was? Genau, das sind die Ungläubigen. Gab es noch irgendwelche Erkenntnisse? Ich hatte mir noch noch irgendwas notiert. Ah ja, genau. Was ja auch sehr interessant war, ist, dass ihr dann noch angekündigt habt, dass sie ja vorhaben, in den nächsten Jahren einen Traffic Service anzubieten.
Wobei für einen Traffic Service, die ja eigentlich auch erstmal noch ein bisschen andere Programme bräuchten, also ich meine noch machen die ja in Richtung Traffic oder Straßen oder Navi mäßig, ist ja bei Apple erstmal noch gar nichts am Start. Nee, das stimmt so gar nicht.
Was denn? Ich war ja am Wochenende im Mailand und da hab ich mich gewundert, warum dann plötzlich mein das Google Maps, so grüne und rote Streifen über den Straßen anzeigt, da war ich das erst mal in einer Stadt, in der Verkehrsdaten da waren.
Aber das Googles.
Ja, es Googles, aber es ist in das Apple Karten, ich nehme an, das Wort Apple geschrieben haben, ist in dem App drinnen. Also insofern, wenn sie da einfach die Datenquelle austauschen, dann haben sie diese Funktion. Also sie können mit den Daten, die sie da aus unseren Bewegungsdaten ermitteln und einfach ein anderes Backend hinterklatschen und schon haben sie das.
Man ist natürlich als so eine riesen Firma, oder nicht als riesen Firma, aber als Firma ist man ja doch immer geneigt, wenn du Positionsdaten von irgendwie 100 Millionen Usern hast. Also wahrscheinlich sind die Positionsdaten von so ein paar tausend oder hunderttausend Usern nicht so interessant, wenn die über die Welt verteilt sind. Aber in dem Augenblick, wo du halt echt 100 Millionen hast und demnächst, keine Ahnung, in so einer Weile 200 Millionen User, dann kann man schon echt eine Menge sehen. Also ich glaube, die könnten sich eine Karte machen, wo die Städte dieser Welt sind, ohne zu wissen, wo die Städte dieser Welt sind, nur anhand der Leute, die sich dort befinden. Und tausend andere Sachen, die da mit so ein bisschen Datenbank, wo du dir zusammenreihen kannst, also wo die Straßen langgehen und eben Verkehrsdaten und all sowas.
Jetzt muss man eigentlich nochmal diese TomTom-Nummer erwähnen, oder?
Ja, wobei ich würde gerne eine andere TomTom-Nummer nochmal vorher erwähnen, die nämlich hier sehr gut zu passen, bevor wir da jetzt auf den Laden einschlagen. Wir hatten das hier auch glaube ich schon mal diskutiert vor langer, langer Zeit. Da hatte ich mich mal mit TomTom ein bisschen unterhalten, wie die das eigentlich so machen, wo die eigentlich so ihre Informationen herbekommen, wie gut, also Informationen darüber, wie schnell man auf Straßen fahren kann, darum ging es in dem Fall. Und tatsächlich hat ja TomTom, und ich denke es gibt mittlerweile auch andere, die das tun, ich weiß bloß nach wie vor nur von dieser Liaison, also TomTom hat dann mit Vodafone zusammengearbeitet. Und Vodafone erhebt diese Daten netzseitig. Das heißt, Vodafone schaut sich einfach an, wo fliegen die ganzen Handys hin und her? Die sehen ja diese Bewegung. Die sehen die ganze Zeit Handys an sich vorbeifahren.
Ja, aber auch deswegen, weil sie diese Daten sammeln, da könnte man jetzt auch wieder diesen...
Das tun die ja schon immer, das ist ja überhaupt nichts Neues. Also, dass man sozusagen auch auf dem Telefon unter Zuhilfenahme des Rückkanals Internet solche Datensammlungen auch machen kann, übersieht halt, dass das schon seit Jahren getan wird, einfach auf Netzseite. Und da kann es natürlich noch viel, viel effizienter gemacht werden, weil es nicht davon abhängt, ob das ein iPhone ist oder was auch immer, sondern das geht mit jedem Telefon, auch mit dem ältesten Nokia 3210, keine Ahnung. Und das fliegt da halt alles rum. Und auf dieser Basis hat Vodafone schon immer Informationen darüber gesammelt, auf welcher Straße kommt man, an welchem Tag, zu welcher Tages- und Nachtzeit, an welchem Wochentag, wie schnell voran. Und das ist diese Information, die bei TomTom in diesen, wie haben sie diese Funktionen genannt, intelligent irgendwas, Maps, mittlerweile ist das glaube ich Standard, mit eingebaut. Genau, diese IQ-Maps-Geschichte.
Dass sie es immer noch nicht schaffen, diese Funktion zu nutzen, um dann zu sagen, ah, hier sind verdammt viele, wo da vorne Telefone gerade auf einen Schlag stehen, stellen wir doch mal zusätzlich noch eine Antenne hin.
Achso, du meinst jetzt, was den Netzausbau betrifft, oder was?
Na ja, wenn es irgendwo Konzerte sind, Republika, große Kongresse, wo...
Du kannst nicht mal eben feststellen, hier sind ganz viele Leute. Lass uns da jetzt mal schnell einen Antrag auf die Errichtung eines Mobilfunkmasses...
Können die keine mobilen Mobilfunkmasses machen? So wie ein Eiswagen, so kommt der Netzwagen vorbei.
Die können ja überall einen Repeater reinhalten, aber das erhöht die Kapazität nicht.
Die Polizei fährt ja regelmäßig zu so Großdemos, mit so einem Verstärkerwagen, irgendwo in so eine Seitenstraße, damit die Polizisten eine Verbindung haben mit ihren... Rocky Talkies nenne ich das jetzt mal.
Solche Repeater.
Genau. Und demnächst dann auch, wenn die irgendwie hier Tetra benutzen, dann werden die auch sowas machen.
Wenn ich mich jetzt mal in so verrückte Staaten wie Iran rein denke und diese ganze Problematik von sich zusammenrottenden Menschenmassen, du kannst natürlich auf Basis einer Echtzeitauswertung solcher Informationen, was nicht ganz einfach ist, aber möglich, kannst du natürlich extreme Crowd-Formation-Data in Echtzeit generieren. Du könntest halt sehen, oh, da rottet sich was zusammen. Viele Punkte gehen an einen Ort und laufen durch die Straße. Und sie bewegen sich in Schrittgeschwindigkeit und nicht in Autogeschwindigkeit. Das sieht nach einer Demo aus.
Wobei eine Demo hat ja normalerweise schon die Angewohnheit, dass sie gerne sichtbar sein möchte und auch dadurch dann im Zweifelsfall den Staatsorgan doch relativ schnell......
Ja, wenn da so ein Mob irgendwie auf deine Regierungsgebäude zu marschiert, um ihn abzubrennen, dann willst du das natürlich auch so früh wie möglich wissen. Wie auch immer. Ich sag nur, es geht. Also man kann einfach aus Sicht des Netzbetreibers, da lässt sich schon eine ganze Menge machen. Und diese Daten sind nicht in Echtzeit. Sie waren eben gesammelt und analysiert und gefiltert und gecampt. Keine Ahnung, was sie da alles machen müssen, um da brauchbare Daten rauszubekommen. Wurden schon immer in solche Traffic-Systeme mit reingemacht. Die Ankündigung von Apple deute ich jetzt im Wesentlichen so, dass sie eben auch die Bewegungen von uns quasi mehr oder weniger auch in Echtzeit interpretieren wollen. Weil es macht ja wohl keinen Sinn, alle 12 Stunden ein Update zu schicken, wie viel, wie der Verkehr hier so läuft.
Aber dafür müssten sie ja dann wirklich die Geräte eindeutig identifizierbar machen. Weil ansonsten kriegst du ja Information nicht hin, wo war er denn vor einer halben Stunde?
Es ist ja ein Unterschied, ob du ein und dasselbe iPhone wiedererkennst oder ob du auch weißt, wem es gehört. Also man kann das schon anonymisieren, aber es bleibt immer das gleiche iPhone. Man könnte natürlich auch alle 12 Stunden die ID wechseln, dann weiß man nicht mehr, ob der heute der gleiche ist wie der gestern. Gibt ja verschiedene Level von anonymisieren. Aber am Ende weißt du nicht, was die da genau machen. Da können die ja auch viel erzählen. Da müssten sie mal einen ranlassen an ihre Datenbank. Aber sowas wird nie passieren.
Ja, wenn sie nicht dazu gezwungen werden, dass...
Ich hab noch nie gehört, dass irgendwie ein Fremder oder ein Staatsbediensteter bei so einer Firma mal in die Datenbank gucken darf, um zu gucken, wie die das da wirklich machen. Also da gibt es ja so Forderungen, dass die Datenschützer da sich mit Apple mal hinsetzen und da mal gucken dürfen. Aber ich meine, am Ende, die kriegen dann auch nur irgendwelche ausgedruckten Papers und wo es da steht, sie ja so machen was.
Meinst du? Nö, ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass die da sagen, okay, ihr müsst ein NDA unterschreiben, aber hier bringt eure Leute, setzt die rein und die dürfen sich das mal angucken. Meinst du, das ist so ein bisschen SQL-Datenbank?
Klar, ich stammt die ganze Zeit in drei, vier Tables fertig.
Ich bin schon mal gespannt, wie viele Datensätze die so pro Tag haben.
Ich würde gerne auch mal die Serverfarm sehen. Ich würde überhaupt gerne mal bei Apple gucken, was die da so haben, also in ganz groß.
Aber TomTom hat jetzt noch diese andere Aktion, die die gebracht haben, ist, wo sich ja auch alle ganz furchtbar drüber aufregen, die haben ja die Daten an den Niederlande verkauft, die Bewegungsdaten ihrer Nutzer. Und das hat ja irgendwie so ein bisschen dazu geführt, dass und angeblich, um rauszukriegen, wo jetzt Ausbaubedarf besteht für Autobahnen und so?
Also die bei TomTom haben sich ja gleich entschuldigt und haben gesagt, sie verkaufen ja öfter Daten an irgendwelche Staaten und so weiter und so fort oder an irgendwelche Behörden, damit die halt auch ihren Ausbau und so weiter besser planen können. Was sich ja auch sehr vernünftig erinnert, da würde man denken, ok, es stimmt ja auch irgendwie, wenn da irgendwie so ein Dorf ist und da immer tausende Autos fahren, klar, wollen die wissen, wie viel denn nun genau wirklich lässt, dann brauchen die ja selbst nicht ihre Straßenzähler los schicken. In Berlin sieht man die öfter mal, dann sitzen die an so einer Kreuzung auf so einem Klappstuhl, haben so einen Zähler in der Hand und müssen für jeden... Gibt's andauernd. Dann müssen sie für jedes Auto, das da vorbeifährt, müssen die einmal klicken und dann gibt's so Spaßvögel, die fahren dann im Kreis und so.
Egal.
Und dann ist natürlich viel leichter, wenn die bei denen groß diese Daten einkaufen können, dann wissen sie, alles klar, hier besteht Bedarf und dann bauen wir mal noch eine Straße und dann wird alles voll toll. So. Und jetzt entschuldigt sich TomTom damit, dass auch die niederländische Polizei hätte auch diese Daten gekauft und hätte die dafür benutzt, um zu gucken, wo denn zu schnell gefahren wird, um da diese Speed-Cameras, die sogenannten bei uns Blitzer genannt, hinzustellen. Und da natürlich aber die Autofahrer eigentlich die Käufer der TomTom-Geräte sind, haben die sich natürlich entschuldigt, weil sie nicht wollen, dass sie mit einem schlechten Image dastehen, dass sie halt sozusagen die Rennleitung unterstützen, also die Polizei, indem die Blitzer entstehen können.
Das ist nicht echt hart gegen Datenfortspeicherung, hat niemand ein Problem, bla, alles harmlos, alles gut, aber die bestellen Blitzer auf?
Das geht gar nicht.
Das Menschenrecht auf zu schnell fahren wird dadurch eingeschränkt? Ich finde das echt.
Jetzt mal die TomTom-Geräte ja dann auch so eine Blitzer-Datenbank haben und dich davor warnen, wenn so ein Blitzer kommt.
Wenn du das kaufst, ja. Kostet ja Geld.
Das wird auch gekauft.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich hab's noch nicht gekauft. Ich würde erst die Blitzer, die da drin sind, darf man kaufen, wenn da die Blitzer drin sind, also nur die Blitzer drin sind, die von hinten blitzen.
Wieso?
Na von vorne, da werde ich so oft geblitzt. Das kannst du gar nicht zielen.
Wegen Motorrad?
Alle Motorradfahrer werden von vorne geblitzt, wie blöd. An jeder Ortseinfahrt, wenn da so ein Ding steht, wirst du erst mal geblitzt.
Das wird nicht mehr lange dauern, dann müsste er die Nummernschilder auch vorne haben.
Da wird sich die Motorradfahrerindustrie beschweren, weil dann kauft gar keiner mehr Motorräder, die brechen eh gerade voll ein.
Die nehmen diese Consolidated-Datenbank von diesem iPhone und das ist überhaupt gar kein Problem. Ja, aber irgendwie viel mit Location-Daten. Oder? Gerade unterwegs. Aber es ist auch sehr lustig, dass wirklich jedes Unternehmen, das diese WLAN-Standpunkte sammelt, irgendwann fliegen sie alle auf die Fresse. Jeder hat seinen kleinen Skandal. Google hatte damals einen Skandal, als sie mit diesen Streetview-Autos rumgefahren sind und die offenen WLAN-Netze abgescannt haben. Außer bei Skyhook, da ahnte das noch keiner, dass das ja mal irgendwann was werden könnte. Da haben sie es noch nicht gemacht.
Dennis, du bist noch nicht im Flugzeugmodus.
Ich hab 433 gerade draufgeschmissen.
Ja, und jetzt bist du nicht mehr im Flugzeugmodus.
Ich war jetzt sowieso noch nie hier.
Dann mach das mal bitte.
Ja, aber wenn ich dann einen Anruf kriege...
Oh mein Gott!
Also ich gucke hier auch gerade noch mal ein bisschen durch meine...
Wenn ich wegen euch einen Boutiqueur verpasse.
Ich hab jetzt mal meine iPhone-Daten konsolidated.db angeschaut. Letztes Mal hatte ich nämlich die von meinem iPad nur. Das hatte ich noch nicht so lange. Aber hier sind doch seit Beginn an, seit ich mein iPhone 4 habe, noch die Daten drauf gewesen.
Nicht sogar noch die älteren?
Macht... Nee.
Das gibt es ja erst seit anderthalb Jahren.
Das war 10. Juni 2010.
Das klingt doch sehr nach iPhone 4. Nein, iOS 4, oder?
Also Sache ist die, dass sie das ja erst machen mit diesen Datenbanken, seitdem sie Skyhawk Wireless gekündigt haben. Und das hat stattgefunden mit iOS Version 3.2. Die hast du aber nicht, weil die nur auf dem iPad gab. Und auf dem iPhone gab es das dann erst mit 4.0.
Naja, auf jeden Fall ist es halt noch komplett da. Und auch wenn da meine Location nicht genau geträgt wird, ich kann schon ziemlich genau, man kann schon ziemlich genau sehen, wo ich langgefahren bin wann.
Ja klar.
Also das ist schon nachvollziehbar.
Ich konnte ja voll toll meine Schwarzwaldreise letztes Jahr sehen. Aber wie es dies schon sagt, das sind halt die Basis-Stationen in der Nähe. Also das ist schon ganz schön oft, ziemlich oft, also links und rechts vom Rand durch so ein Waldbrett, dann sind es halt die Basis-Stationen irgendwo außerhalb des Waldes, wo halt mal einer ist und nicht da, wo du langgefahren bist. Also ich will jetzt nicht sagen, dass man einen damit nicht trecken könnte, das schon. Aber es ist schon auch teilweise sehr ungenau.
Also ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass das für irgendjemand, wenn du wegen irgendwas angeklagt bist, und sagen wir mal, jetzt nehmen wir mal an, da wird ja wohl auch ganz gerne mal getreckt diese, so beweisen sie doch mal, dass sie nicht in der Nähe von diesem Auto waren, was jetzt abgebrannt ist oder sowas. Und dass du da, wenn da die Polizei an diese Daten rankommt, dass sie dann schon sagen, Moment mal, sie waren noch am 5.3. da in Hamburg und haben in der Nähe sich von diesem Auto was dann abgefackeltes aufgehalten. Und drei Tage später waren sie in der Nähe, als das andere Auto abgebrannt ist.
In Berlin bist du immer in der Nähe von einem abgewandten Auto. Alle.
Ja, das macht ja das Problem. Und daraus könnte man ja schon schöne Daten sammeln, glaube ich.
Also wir stellen mal fest, diese Datei hatte an sich einen guten Sinn.
Aus Apples Sicht?
Aus Apples Sicht und aus Nutzer Sicht könnte man sagen, man kann sich schlecht informiert gefühlt haben, aber dass diese Funktion grundsätzlich vorhanden ist, ist ja bekannt gewesen. Ja gut, aber das ist ja nicht eben klar. Die Frage ist, sagt es dir dein Telefonhersteller, dass er das tut? Und was sie nicht gesagt haben, ist, dass diese Datei da so vorliegt. Und vermutlich haben sie das vor allem auch deshalb mich gesagt, weil sie es selber nicht gewusst haben. Also das kann ich mir einfach realistisch vorstellen, dass das einfach so eine Verpeilung war mit diesem Cash.
Das haut aber auch nicht ganz hin, weil die Leute, diese Forensiker, die auch dieses Buch geschrieben haben, haben es ja im November wohl schon geschrieben, dass das da alles so existiert. Und die bei Apple sind ja nicht ganz betriebsblind, die müssen uns ja auch ein bisschen kümmern, was über sie geschrieben wird, und die haben das auf jeden Fall auch gelesen. Die haben da auch eine Security-Ecke und ein paar Notes dabei.
Da wäre ich mir halt einfach gar nicht so sicher.
Der Laden ist so groß, dass es vielleicht Apple heute gelesen haben, aber nicht die in der richtigen Abteilung?
Ja, auf jeden Fall kam das irgendwie nicht zu den... Weiß ich nicht. Ganz offensichtlich kam es ja nicht durch.
Nein, ganz offensichtlich ist das nicht. Das ist ganz offensichtlich, nur wenn man deren Erklärung eins zu eins übernimmt. Also ich könnte mir schon noch vorstellen, dass die sich gesagt haben, ja, okay, ist vielleicht jetzt ein bisschen fragwürdig, aber wir wollen unsere schöne Datenbank mal aufbauen und wir ziehen das jetzt mal so durch. Und wenn die sich dann ja alle beschweren, ist auch egal, weil dann ist unsere Datenbank voll und ab da können wir dann auch mit ein bisschen irgendwie weniger Speed fahren.
Ich hab diese Funktion dieser Datenbank auf dem Gerät so verstanden, dass um mich zu lokalisieren, muss ich ohne GPS, muss mein Telefon wissen, welchen Masten in der Nähe sind. Das sagt aha, da ist ein Mast, da ist ein Mast, da ist ein Mast. Und fragt dann bei Apple nach, wo stehen diese Masten? Und dann wird diese Information mitgeteilt von Apple an mein Telefon. Und mein Telefon speichert diese Information danach in den Cash. Damit, wenn ich das nächste Mal da wieder vorbeikomme, und die Chance, dass jemand, der heute da vorbeigeht, morgen wieder an diesem Ort vorbeigeht, ist relativ hoch, und wieder an die Karte guckt, damit mein Telefon morgen weiß, ohne diesmal bei Apple nachfragen zu müssen, sag mal, wo stehen diese Sendemasten? Und hin und wieder werden diese Daten eben aktuell...
Ja, nicht bei Apple nachfragen, sondern ohne auf GPS...
Na, auch ohne bei Apple nachzufragen. Wenn ich am selben Ort morgen nochmal bin und wieder die gleichen Geräte in der Nähe sind, wie sie gestern waren, dann braucht er nämlich nicht bei Apple nachzufangen, sondern kann das aus dieser Datenbank rausnehmen.
Okay, jetzt verstehe ich das so meist.
Und darum ist es eventuell ganz interessant, diese Daten nicht nach einer Woche oder zwei wegzuschmeißen, sondern über einen möglichst langen Zeitraum mitzuschneiden und aufzuheben im Gerät, weil es ja eigentlich auch nicht weh tut. Und ja, und dann macht das ja Sinn. Ich finde das eigentlich total sinnvoll, dass diese Dateien nicht weggeschmissen werden. Ich finde, das ist eine absolut logische Erklärung, die man nicht über einen Bug erklären muss. Warum nicht? Weil es auch in einem Jahr...
Weil es dann schon potentiell im Falle der Verlust ist deines Telefons...
Klar, den Fall haben sie nämlich mit bedacht. Aber aus der rein technischen Perspektive...
Man könnte natürlich jetzt auch sagen, es sind ja auch noch viele andere Daten drauf. Deine E-Mail, was weiß ich, Passwörter etc. Also wenn du jetzt wirklich Zugriff hast auf den Backup oder Zugriff hast auf das Telefon selbst, dann kann halt jemand mit halbwegstechnischem Wissen über iPhone aufmachen, etc. Jailbreak-Daten rausholen, Backup, etc.
Weißte so ziemlich, aber viel schlimmer zurzeit. Jede App auf deinem MacBook kann diese Daten lesen. Na, weil die da rumliegen durch das Backup.
Ja, wenn das Backup nicht verschlüsselt ist.
Verschlüsselt oder lässt das Backup?
Ist es eigentlich bei Default mittlerweile verschlüsselt? Zu sicher?
Ich glaube nicht.
Auch wenn man so ein neues OS installiert und ein neues Telefon kauft und nicht irgendwie seine Setups von vor drei Jahren noch mit sich zieht?
Na, also es wird ja in dem Moment, in dem man ein neues Gerät sich kauft, zum Beispiel wenn man sich ein neues iPad kauft, dann wird ja ein neues Backup angelegt. Also dann wird ja ein neues Gerät in das Backup angelegt, und das ist erstmal nicht verschlüsselt. Das habe ich ja gerade erst vor sehr kurzer Zeit gemacht.
Also der Chat meint, man muss das einschalten. Naja, dann muss es wahr sein.
Genau.
Quelle-Chat.
Ja, Problem, wenn man auf seinem Programm, auf seinem Gerät laufen hat, die können auch deine Daten zugreifen. Das ist eigentlich keine große Neuigkeit. Das sollte jedem bewusst sein. Wenn mein iPhone wegkommt und jemand kann damit umgehen, dann hat er sehr, sehr viele persönliche Daten über mich. Dann hat er nicht nur meine E-Mail, dann hat er meine Search History, dann hat er vielleicht einen Haufen Passwörter, dann kann er gucken, mein Highscore in diversen Spielen und wie wir jetzt erfahren haben, was sicherlich, was ich glaube nicht mal das größte Problem wäre, aber was natürlich ein sehr, sehr präsentes Problem ist, ist ein auch grob, wo du dich aufgehalten hast. Oder?
Ja.
Wir wissen sogar ziemlich genau, wo du dich aufgehalten hast.
Es ist eine Information, die man so nicht hätte anwachsen lassen müssen, aber es ist jetzt auch nicht so ein Big Deal. Also zumindest rechtfertig ist es meiner Meinung nach jetzt nicht die Aufregung. Insbesondere, weil es sicher auch so abzeichnet, dass bei anderen Unternehmen die Sache unter Umständen nicht genau so läuft wie bei Apple. Mr. Jobs ist ja nicht müde geworden, das anzudeuten, ohne irgendwie genauer zu erklären. Ich habe den nicht wirklich intensiv hinterher recherchieren können. Es steht so ein bisschen die Behauptung im Raum, dass auf Android sehr wohl ein Tracking stattfindet. Aber in welcher Form? Weiß ich nicht. Keine Ahnung.
Ich habe irgendetwas gelesen von einer fast identischen Datenbank, die nicht so lange anwächst, aber die auch vorsichtig ist.
Genau, die Frage ist, wie diese Updates dann halt laufen. Also ob da auch eine Geräte-ID zum Beispiel mitgesendet wird oder nicht. Apple behauptet sie tun das nicht.
Ach so, an Android, also bei Google. Sie müssen es ja machen, wenn sie so eine eigene Datenbank aufbauen wollen.
Nein, sie müssen es ja nicht machen, haben wir doch schon mehrfach festgestellt.
Nee, eine Geräte-ID müssen sie sich nicht finden. Aber wenn sie so eine Crowdsourced-Datenbank aufbauen wollen, dann müssen sie...
Ja, aber diese Behauptung hab ich gesehen.
Ach, dass ich da sogar eine eindeutig...
Ja, aber ich hab keinen Beleg, also nichts gesehen, gelesen, die mich jetzt hätte glauben müssen.
Ich glaube, das hätte nochmal eine größere Welle geschoben.
Genau, ja, der Chat meint auch, wird angeblich, aber wer das jetzt angeblich, also wer das angibt, ist zu diesem Zeitpunkt dieser Diskussion in diesem Raum unklar. Und wir wollen jetzt hier auch nicht anfangen, groß irgendwas zu behaupten. Oder wir überlassen das behaupten dem Chat.
Der Chat behauptet?
Na ja, Apple hat jetzt in wie schnell irgendwie diesen Backe fixt. Wann war das Problem? Vor zwei Wochen. Sie haben also zwei Wochen gebraucht, genau exakt wie der heute. Genau zwei Wochen gebraucht, um ihre vielen Bugs, die sie auch sozusagen eingestanden haben, zu beheben. Und das nicht mehr ins Backup zu spielen. Und das auch noch gelöscht wird, wenn man irgendwie seine Lokalisierung abschaltet. Also auch aus Apples Sicht fand Apple wohl, dass die, wie sagt man, die Bedenken der User halt gegründet sind. Oder gerechtfertigt sind, genau.
Ah ja, oder sie haben sich gedacht, wir müssen irgendwie reagieren, damit es wieder ein bisschen ruhiger wird, kann ich mir auch gut vorstellen.
Ob das jetzt wirklich ein Problem für die Leute ist, oder ob man nur sagt, ja, das ist halt mehr so ein Psycho-Ding, ist ja total egal. Wenn der User sich damit nicht so wohlfühlt, sollte man halt was dagegen tun. Und ich denke, Apple hat die Datenbank vollgemacht und die können jetzt halt eben das ein bisschen entspannter einsammeln. Oder sie haben es wirklich vergessen.
Also wie gesagt, ich glaube, dass diese Datenbank nur zu einem Bruchteil wirklich dazu da ist, um die Daten… Also ich glaube nicht, dass diese 50 Megabyte Datei irgendwann genommen wird und an Apple geschickt wird, so an einem Stück. Sondern ich glaube, diese Datenbank ist genau das Gegenteil. Sie ist das, sie ist für mein Telefon die Möglichkeit, sich zu orten, ohne auf GPS angewiesen zu sein und im glücklichsten Fall ohne auf eine Internetverbindung angewiesen zu sein. Da gibt es ja wohl auch dieses Phänomen, dass man auch ein iPad ohne Internetverbindung sich plötzlich positionieren kann, obwohl es das vorher nicht konnte, wenn es sich einmal an dem Ort positioniert hat. Also wenn du einmal eine Internetverbindung hattest und da mit der Karte gesagt hast, dann kann ein iPad auch in Zukunft ohne Internetverbindung. Ich glaube, das ist genau dieser Datenbank. Was jetzt nur noch sieben Tage lang geht, ja. Wahrscheinlich werden als nächstes alle meckern, dass ihr ihr Map so lange braucht und sich ständig nachher positionieren muss.
Dann müssen sie noch öfter bei Apple nachfragen und kriegt Apple schon wieder mehr Daten. So einfach ist das. Vielleicht ging es ja sogar wirklich gerade nach hinten los.
Es funktioniert genau in die andere Richtung. Kann natürlich sein.
Wir haben es gefixt, alle sind happy. Also, nee, alle bestimmt nicht, aber viele.
Alles wird gut.
Gut, dass ihr anderen Unternehmen alles besser macht.
Jetzt endlich zu den wichtigen Themen.
Das weiße iPad. Endlich.
Der weiße Riese.
Hast du es schon gesehen?
Nur auf Fotos.
Ja, sieht nicht schlecht aus. Nur auf Fotos.
Also wenn es genauso schick ist wie dein iPad.
Aber es wird dich interessant, dass sie einfach eine andere Farbe, sie wirklich 10 Monate zusätzliches Engineering gekostet hat.
Dann kannst du mal sehen, wie viel Mühe die sich geben. Das ist nicht irgendein weiß.
Wie lange die dann im Schwarz gesessen haben.
Vor allem die Modifikationen, die sie jetzt tatsächlich getan haben, sind auch interessant.
Ist es wirklich dicker? Oder war das ein Fake? Es gibt jetzt Gerüchte, dass es nicht dicker ist.
Es ist nicht dicker. Hat Schilder gesagt, getwittert hat das.
Ja, also Messfehler.
Vermutlich kann ja auch sein, weiß nicht, keine Ahnung. Vielleicht hat er eins, wo Toleranz war, oder vielleicht hat er Sand auf dem Tisch liegen gehabt. Ich meine die Angabe 0,2 Millimeter.
Bei knapp 10 Millimeter sind das 2 Prozent.
Ja, es gab Fotos auf dem Internet.
Auf dem Internet.
Na gut, darüber muss man es ja nun wirklich nicht groß.
Aber ich möchte mich wissen, wie andere, wie irgendwelche Marketing-Manager und Presse-Manager bei anderen Telefonherstellern geweint haben, dass Apple mit diesem Gerät eine neue Farbe eines Geräts, die seit 10 Monaten angekündigt ist und einfach nicht gekommen ist, was die damit für eine Welle gemacht haben.
Ja.
Ich meine, ich steff euch mal vor, Nokia könnte wahrscheinlich die gesamte Produktlinie austauschen und würde nicht so einen Medienecho erreichen wie Apple mit diesem dämlichen, weißen iPhone.
Was soll ich dazu sagen? Also meine, welche Modifikation gibt's? Die Kamera ist jetzt tiefer im Gerät. Das ist eine Änderung. Also dieser Kegel quasi, in den diese Linse eingelassen ist. Beim weißen iPhone tiefer als beim schwarzen. Das kann schon mal eine nennenswerte Änderung gewesen sein, weil sie unter Umständen überhaupt erst eine komplett neue Kamera haben entwickeln müssen, die mit dem entsprechenden Platz dann auch noch rauskommt.
Nee, die Kamera ist wohl die gleiche.
Was sagt ihr, dass es die gleiche ist, wenn sie doch ganz anders aussieht?
Weil eben nur dieser Kegel drauf wohl anders aussieht. Also ich hab irgendwo gelesen, Tier down, bla bla bla, hat einen anderen Kegel, aber ist die gleiche Kamera.
Dann ist halt dieser, was bei dem Schwarzen nur so ein kleines Löchlein ist, also es ist noch nicht mal ein Löchlein, es ist so ein, man sieht das auch nur, wenn man irgendwie Licht drauf macht, dieser Annäherungssensor. Das seh ich jetzt hier gerade bei dem Licht gar nicht, aber der ist ja so ein bisschen oberhalb der Kamera bei dem Schwarzen iPhone.
Ist das noch so ein Schlitz?
Nee, das ist eben kein Schlitz, aber jetzt ist es halt ein Schlitz bei dem Weißen.
Also ich seh den gar nicht.
Man sieht den bei Tageslicht.
Also ich hab auf diesen Prototypen, die nie rausgekommen sind, das hat ja oben so ein Raster von Schwarzen, also so irgendwie acht oder so was schwarze Pünktchen und jetzt das finale Gerät hat dann tatsächlich so ein Schlitz drinnen.
Hier oben ist so ein Schlitz über dem Lautsprecher, über dem Lautsprecherschlitz da oben drüber ist noch einer so, keine Ahnung, sechs Millimeter breit, ein Millimeter hoch.
Genau und der ist jetzt halt bei dem weißen iPhone doch ganz viel mehr sichtbar. Das sieht man hier schon auf den normalen Produktfotos, ist der einfach voll groß, fett und sichtbar. Und wenn man sich halt dagegen die offiziellen Produktfotos von dem Schwarzen anschaut, da ist das halt überhaupt nicht zu sehen.
Naja, ich hab jetzt hier mal welche rausgesucht. Das waren, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht, die Fotos von dem, als es damals angekündigt worden ist, das weiße iPhone, da war das so eine Reihe von Punkten, die da oben drin war, über dem Lautsprecher, quasi eine kleine. Und jetzt ist es wirklich so ein richtiger Schlitz, der da oben drauf ist.
Aber er war da auch schon sichtbar.
Ja, er war da auch sichtbar, aber es sah aus, als ob da so wie so eine Membran 8 oder so was Pünktchen drin wären. Also da haben sie offensichtlich irgendwas verbessert. Und es wurde ja auch die ganze Zeit immer gerüchtet, dass das große Problem daran wäre an dem iPhone, nämlich dass der Blitz und die Kamera nicht gemeinsam vernünftig will und dass die Sensoren irgendwie spinnen. Und an beiden Stellen haben sie offensichtlich nachgebessert.
Na ja, und dann noch irgendwie so UV-Schutz. Also irgendwie ist ihnen das Weiß wahrscheinlich auch noch ausgeglichen. Ich frage mich, warum sie das überhaupt so kurz vor dem Launch erst bemerkt haben.
Ja, so eine richtig extrem hohe Priorität kann es auch nicht gehabt haben. Ansonsten wäre das sicherlich doch schon ein bisschen früher gekommen, oder?
Keine Ahnung. Sieht aber nett aus. Kann man, wird sich sicherlich verkaufen.
Ich hab hier irgendwie so ein...
Wobei ich immer noch nicht verstehe, warum sich irgendwie Apple nicht an den großen, erfolgreichen Softwareunternehmen Microsoft orientiert und mal ein braunes iPhone aufbaut.
Das hab ich getwittert, hat keiner so verstanden. Und immer schön dran denken.
Ich hätte ja gerne ein blaues Smartphone abwechseln.
Könnt ihr euch noch an den blauen iPod erinnern?
Den es nie gab?
Es gab doch mal...
Kannst du dich noch an einen iPod erinnern?
HP hat doch mal eine Zeit lang den iPod verkauft. Mit HP-Logo hinten drauf statt Apple-Logo.
Das war aber auch nur für drei Tage, oder?
Nee, das war gar nicht ganz am Anfang. Und da gab es auch einen Prototypen von, nämlich als der Deal angekündigt worden ist, hat die HP-Chefin, ich glaube, war eine Frau damals, rumgerannt und hat so einen Prototypen von einem HP-iPod in der Hand gehalten, in so einem unglaublich hässlichen Blauton, HP-Blauton. Weil damals alles wohl von HP in diesem Blauton war und darum musste auch das sein. Und er ist niemals in der Farbe auf den Markt gekommen.
Stimmt.
Und ich hab neulich eine tolle Verschwörungstheorie gehört, dass das nur gemacht worden sei, damit, also dass Apple sich damals auf diesen Deal eingelassen hätte, um, also sie haben gesagt, HP, ihr dürft unseren iPod verkaufen, mit einem eigenen Label, aber dafür müsst ihr euren eigenen MP3-Player einstanzen.
Es gab ja dann viele, viele bunte iPod-Nanos und Minis und so weiter, die waren ja auch alle bunt.
Hier ist nochmal schön nebeneinander Sensorleiste beim original angekündigten Anstohnen und beim finalen Gerät.
Na gut, jetzt haben wir uns, jetzt haben wir die wirklich, die wichtigsten Themen jetzt schon verbraten. Das soll aufhören zu atmen?
Ja, das wollte ich unauffällig andeuten.
Das hab ich schon vor Monaten aufgegeben.
Ich hab mir gestern sagen lassen müssen, dass ich schmatze. Zu viel.
Aber nur beim Essen.
Nein, nein, auch hier beim Reden so.
So, wollen wir mal wieder ein bisschen mehr über Max reden?
Wir sollten mal mehr über Max reden.
Also, es gibt ja jetzt so einen neuen Syncing-Dienst, den ich ganz interessant finde. Ich kann auch nicht wirklich behaupten, dass ich ihn ausgiebig getestet hätte, aber zumindest hab ich ihn schon mal ein wenig ausprobiert. Heißt aerofs.com und gibt's angeblich für Windows, Mac und Linux. Hab ich für Mac ausprobiert und ist halt so ein Dropbox-Ansatz. Allerdings ohne Cloud. Oder zumindest erstmal ohne zwingenden Grund mit Cloud zu arbeiten. Sondern es ist halt nur Peer to Peer und du bist sozusagen dein Peer. Sprich, du kannst dir diese Software runterladen auf jeden deiner Macs und kannst dann sagen, du möchtest jetzt hier so einen aerofs-Ordner sharen. Also sie nennen es genau genommen eine Library, du hast halt diesen aerofs-Ordner und da drin hast du dann eben verschiedene Unterordner, die dann eben deine Libraries sind. Und du kannst dann eben sharen. Und das Syncing zwischen den Rechnern geht halt wirklich von Rechner zu Rechner.
Das heißt, die müssen auch immer alle laufen?
Die müssen nicht alle laufen, sondern sie syncen halt dann, wenn sie laufen und wenn du halt immer etwas haben willst, womit syncen musst du halt eine Maschine haben, die immer erreichbar ist und immer läuft. Das ist halt der Nachteil. Wenn du keine Cloud hast, dann läuft es halt so. Aber soweit ich das beurteilen kann, funktioniert das tatsächlich. Ich habe jetzt noch nicht so richtig fett damit rumgespielt und ich habe euch auch irgendwie eingeladen.
Du hast mich eingeladen?
Aber ihr habt da nicht drauf reagiert.
Ich habe darauf reagiert. Ich habe darauf reagiert. Ich habe da sogar auch eine Datei reingepackt, die siehst du hoffentlich auch schon.
Ernsthaft.
Also ich habe mir das dann runtergeladen, habe das installiert, hatte erstmal das Problem, dass nämlich eine Fehlermeldung kam, so dass ja, der andere Rechner ist gerade nicht online.
Genau.
Und irgendwann war die Datei dann einfach da, vermutlich dann zu einem Zeitpunkt, an dem wir beide online waren. Und dann habe ich mir mal den Spaß gemacht und habe eine Datei zurückgepackt.
Ah, dieses test.txt. Genau. Deshalb ist mir jetzt gar nicht ans Auge gesprungen. Aber es fand ja dann auch tatsächlich zu funktionieren.
Das funktioniert. Ich fände ja so eine Lösung. Also ich will ja dieses Cloud-Scheiß.
Es gibt da wohl Cloud dazu zum Backupen. Aber es ist halt erstmal nicht zwingend. Und die Software so an sich ist soweit erstmal frei. Und ihr Modell ist dann, dass sie dir quasi dazu den Backup-Storage kaufen. Und es ist halt alles verschlüsselt. Das heißt, die Kommunikation ist verschlüsselt. Und die Maschinen haben halt irgendwie eigene Keys. Sodass das ebenso das Versprechen, die Behauptung, ja, quasi dir dein Verteilen von Daten ermöglicht, zwischen verschiedenen Rechnern, ohne dass du in irgendeiner Form auf Cloud zugreifen musst. Was ich nicht weiß, ist, wie sich die Rechner finden. Ich vermute mal, dass sie da schon noch so einen Lokalisierungsdienst haben. Dass sie also über ihre Domänen quasi das Anklopfen machen, mit Hallo, ich bin hier und IP-Adresse etc. Vielleicht machen sie es mit Wide Area Bonjour, weiß ich nicht. Kann sein.
Kann nicht sein. Das läuft dann quasi so, in dem Moment, in dem du mir Daten schickst, sagt mein Gerät... Ach, das ist ja nur die...
In dem Moment, wo ich am Internet bin, stellt er vermutlich fest oder checkt regelmäßig, welche anderen Rechner, mit denen er so verbunden sein sollte.
Nein, ich war gerade so total offen, dass die Speicherung ja auch verschlüsselt sein muss, muss sie ja aber gar nicht, weil...
Das sind einfach normale Fälle, die auf deiner Platte rumliegen. Naja, auf jeden Fall, wir sollten da noch ein bisschen mehr andere Sachen auch mal testen. Es gibt da noch viele ungetestetes hier so, Voila und wie sie alle heißen. Habe ich jetzt alles noch nicht so richtig im Einsatz gehabt. Ja, Leute, die damit glücklich geworden sind. Ich kenne auch Leute, die sind damit nicht glücklich geworden. Dann gibt es auch Crash Plan. Das ist auch noch so ein Tool. Das hat man auch, glaube ich, alles schon mal erwähnt. Bin aber leider noch nie dazu gekommen, das mal so wirklich ernsthaft zu testen.
Ach, Voila ist dieser Lassi-Dienst. Kriegt man das auch ohne Lassi-Festplatte?
Ich denke schon.
25 GB 40 € im Jahr. 1 GB kostenlos.
Also was mir bei Aero AFS jetzt einfach erstmal gefällt ist, du kriegst das, was du nämlich im Wesentlichen möchtest, nämlich das Syncing deiner Dateien zwischen verschiedenen Rechnern. Kriegst du einfach mal for free und du benutzt halt keinerlei Cloud Storage. Deine Daten sind nicht auf anderer Leute Festplatten. Egal, ob verschlüsselt oder unverschlüsselt, das ist erstmal die Prämisse. Deswegen fand ich das an sich erstmal cool. Du kannst das einfach benutzen, um irgendwelche Rechner miteinander zu verbinden, ohne dass du von irgendeiner Infrastruktur abhängig bist, außer deiner eigenen.
Und dadurch hat man halt auch nicht dieses Problem, dass irgendwann die Platte voll ist. Also, dass die virtuelle Platte voll ist.
Genau.
So wie es ja bei Dropbox schon mal gerne passiert, dass die Platte einfach mal überläuft.
Genau, und dann kostet Geld und so.
Oder nervt.
Dropbox war ja auch ordentlich in der Kritik, was ihre ganze Verschlüsselungsgeschichte betrifft. Sie haben ja immer viel behauptet, das wäre ja alles verschlüsselt und so.
Ich glaube, das ist auch verschlüsselt. Ich glaube, sie haben da nie gelogen.
Na, es kann nicht verschlüsselt sein.
Doch, es ist alles mit dem selben Key verschlüsselt.
Das glaube ich nicht. Ja, oder so. Es ist verschlüsselt, aber überall liegen die Schlüssel rum, so nach dem Motto.
Naja, was heißt überall liegen die rum?
Wie sollte das Web-Interface sonst in der Lage sein, dir da Inhaltsverzeichnisse anzuzeigen? Wenn das so verschlüsselt ist, dass sie darauf nicht zugreifen können, dann müsst sie ihre eigene Web-Anwendung da auch versagen. Es sei denn, dein Passwort, mit dem du dich einloggst, ist dann dieser Schlüssel.
Naja, oder dein Passwort ist der Schlüssel für den eigentlichen, um den eigentlichen Schlüssel zu erschlüsseln.
Aber dem ist...
Dem ist nicht so.
Dem ist einfach nicht so. Und sie haben dann auch irgendwie zugegeben, dass sie ja auch den Diensten jederzeit da die Tür öffnen, wie sie es einfach zu tun haben, wenn sie einen solchen Request bekommen. Ihr überhauptet gerade, es ist gegenüber Amazon S3 verschlüsselt. Also Amazon kann nicht reingucken.
Also die Dropbox-Bude nutzt einen externen Dienstleister für den Storage anscheinend, das ist Amazon S3. Und da wird halt verschlüsselt, so dass Amazon nicht reingucken kann, sondern nur die Dropbox-Bude selbst.
Ja gut. Ich meine, das ist ja auch so eine Sache, weil sie haben ja unter anderem dieses Feature, dass sie am Hash einer Datei erkennen, ob diese Datei schon da ist. Und dann gab es jetzt diesen schönen Hack. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das mitbekommen habt. Wie heißt das nochmal? AirDrop? Nee, nicht AirDrop. War das AirDrop?
Ich glaube, AirDrop ist dieses Apple-Feature. Das ist was anderes.
Richtig. Oder hieß es nicht trotzdem AirDrop? Auf jeden Fall haben irgendwelche Jungs quasi gegen dieses Dropbox-AP-Code gehackt, sich sozusagen als Client ausgegeben, der sich normal verhält und einfach behauptet, dass sie eine Datei mit einem bestimmten Hasch hätten. Was dann, also, kannst du halt einfach den Hasch quasi selber ausdenken von irgendeinem großen DVD-Rip oder sonstige Images.
Um rauszufinden, was bei denen alles so rumliegt.
Nee, du kannst auch einfach behaupten, dass du das in deinem Verzeichnis hast.
Sie teilen Dropbox mit?
Es muss ja dann nicht nochmal hochgeladen werden, weil es ja schon da ist. Du behauptest einfach gegenüber Dropbox, dass es da ist. Dropbox sagt dann, oh, aha, brauchst du mir nicht hochschicken, weil hab ich ja schon. Und auf einem anderen Rechner, wo die Datei aber nicht ist, von deinemselben Account, muss es aber dann ja runtergeladen werden. Und dann lädt dir Dropbox diese Datei, obwohl du sie nicht hattest, auf deinen Rechner runter, auf Basis der Behauptung deines zweiten Clients, dass du diese Datei hast. Das haben sie ja zugegeben, dass sie das jetzt abgeschaltet haben.
Es gab ja so ein Fallstellen, jetzt wird auf der Basis.
Okay, dann haben die aber ein bisschen verkackt da.
Da haben sie richtig verkackt. Musst du nochmal diesen Link finden.
Ich glaube, das ist aber nur auf Interface-Seite verkackt. In ihrer DB werden die das nicht verkackt haben, dann hat es so ein Problem. Weil die werden schon Hashes aufnehmen, die wirklich auch bei denen da rumliegen und nicht die einer von extern irgendwie angibt. Dann wäre das ja ganz schön verkackt.
Nee, das ist, guck mal, ich meine, das ist einfach ein... Du willst mir eine große... Wir bauen jetzt ein tolles File Sharing-Netzwerk auf. Und zwar jeder von uns legt diese Datei auf Dropbox. Nehmen wir mal an, du möchtest mir jetzt Fotos von dir zukommen lassen. Oder beziehungsweise einer großen Menschengruppe, dann legst du die auf deine Dropbox, guckst nach, welchen Hash hast du, packst den Hash auf deine Website und sagt, wenn ihr diese Datei wollt, dann müsst ihr bei euch diesen Hash installieren. Und dann kannst du mit diesem Dropship, kannst Dropbox behaupten, die Behauptung, also gegenüber sozusagen, behaupten, ich hab diesen Hash hier und gib mir mal die Datei dazu. Dann hat der Dropbox die Datei runtergeladen, sodass du schön ein Peer-to-Peer Netzwerk, Peer-to-Peer ist nicht ein Fall-Sharing-Netzwerk, das man natürlich für viele bunte Sachen nutzen kann.
Aber ich denk, die behaupten den Hash zu haben von einer Sache, die nicht bei denen liegt. Du hast jetzt ja nur den normalen Vorgang beschrieben.
Nee, der normale Vorgang wäre, dass du vorher sharen musst den Ordner und dass dann sozusagen dir alle Dateien rübergeschoben werden. In dem Fall ist es einfach, sobald die irgendwo in ihrem Netzwerk, sobald, ich hab das schon gemacht, wenn ich unten MP3 hochspiele in meine Dropbox, dann ist die plötzlich extrem schnell da oben.
Weil die schon jemand anderes da hatte und die haben lokal bei dir den Hasch erstellt, haben bei Dropbox geguckt, alles klar, den haben wir hier schon und dann...
Und genau den geht es sozusagen als vorhanden.
Brauchen wir nur noch speichern, dass du die auch wieder runterladen darfst, weil du ja... Genau.
Exakt, genau das machen sie. Außer, dass sie eben jetzt nur an Dropbox den Hasch schicken und sagen, du, ich hab diese Datei hier übrigens und dann Dropbox sagt, alles klar, dann hast du ja dieses MP3, hier hast du das MP3 und schon hast du das MP3 und hast nur den Hasch reingepackt.
Das wird ja ein Saukerlack. Ja, und da du da halt problemlos von vielen Dateien, also du musst ja sozusagen nur noch den Hasch übermitteln, das ist ja noch besser als BitTorrents.
Das ist eigentlich nur die Torrent-Datei.
Nein, das ist doch nicht mal die Torrent-Datei. Du brauchst nur den Hasch.
Nein, in der Torrent-Datei steht ja normalerweise auch das Hasch.
Und die Haschen...
Kurze Frage, die Haschen immer die gesamte Datei.
Vermutlich.
Weil ich kenne ja hier, wie auch schon einer im Chat hier meint, bei ZFS gibt es ja Deduplication, die machen das gleich auf Block-Ebene. Und dann kann sich auch eine Datei immer ändern, dann wird halt nur die Änderung, also der kleine Block, gespeichert, aber der Rest kann immer gleich bleiben, weil da die Hasch ist immer noch, die restlichen Blöcke. Das heißt, man müsste dann bei Dropbox irgendwie, weiß nicht, was sie benutzen für einen Hasch, aber sagen wir mal SHA-256 oder so, dann geht man da, weil das wird bei BitTorrent nämlich auch benutzt, geht man bei denen hin, holt sich diesen Hasch und schummelt sich das dann zurecht und lädt sich das runter.
Stimmt, wie hoch wird denn die Wahrscheinlichkeit gewesen sein, dass das bei BitTorrent dasselbe war und dass du dir einfach eine Torrent-Datei nehmen kannst und mit der diesen Hasch erzeugen? Ist jetzt nicht so extrem unwahrscheinlich, Apfel.
Also der Code liegt auf Github rum, wenn sie da angucken, ist alles überhaupt gar kein großes Geheimnis.
Das ist egal, haben sie ja schon gefixt.
Nee, nee, haben sie nicht gefixt.
Ich dachte, hätten sie.
Ich dachte auch, dass sie das gefixt haben.
Haben sie jetzt einen Fix dafür? Nee, ich hab nur gehört, dass ein Bepär DCMA, Take Down Notice, probiert haben, dieses Projekt zu beseitigen. Und dass das dann so ein bisschen in die Hose ging. Sonst hätte das ja nicht so einen Aufstand gemacht.
Das kommt davon, wenn man sich seine Quellen nicht ausreichend notiert.
Ja, Quellenschutz.
Also wenn das Ding immer noch offen ist, dann ist es natürlich wirklich mega cool.
Naja, ich glaube, sie müssten schon auf ihrem Backend und bei allen Kleinen die Hasht-Funktion ändern.
Ich weiß nicht genau, was sie dagegen gemacht haben.
Also was ich gelesen habe, was natürlich eine einfache Möglichkeit gewesen wäre, das zu verhindern wäre.
Das Backend fordert so ein paar Sample Bites an.
Genau.
Und zu beweisen, dass du es auch wirklich hast.
Immer mal wieder random-mäßig. Ich kann sie ja auch verdacht machen. Das muss ja nicht sogar immer stattfinden, je nachdem, wie sie ausgelassen sind und ob sie Zeit haben.
Exakt. Das war also in dem Moment, in dem der Client sagt, guck mal, ich hab hier der Datei mit diesem Hashtrenner. Einfach nochmal nachfragen. Aha, dann gib mir doch mal byte 45 bis 98. Und das immer zufällig machen. Und wenn er das nicht geben kann, dann weiß man, dass man das mit einem Betrug zu tun hat. Aber man muss trotzdem überall die Clients aktualisieren. Ja, ich weiß nicht. Ich verderne... Genau, bei Köhlen-Top stand das. Ich fand das... Die haben eine schlechte Update-Funktion bei Dropbox. Ich bin da noch nie... Auch wenn eine neue Version auf der Website drauf war, hat mir der Dropbox-Client immer gesagt, nee, du hast die neueste Version. Kein Grund abzudaten. Insofern kann ich mir vorstellen, dass ihnen das nicht total einfach gefallen wäre.
Also ich bin nach wie vor verwirrt, ob sie jetzt gegen dieses Dropship schon was getan haben oder sich nur juristisch wehren.
Sie müssen auf jeden Fall ein bisschen was umstellen im Coding. Also da müssen sie sich schon noch was einfallen lassen.
Sie müssen halt irgendwie einen Beweis haben. Dass diese Datei auch wirklich vorliegt.
Also du sagst, du hast folgende Datei. Also das neueste Lion Image hast du, der den Hasch dir besorgt. Und gib es dann an und sagst, du hättest es. Und dann sag ich als Backend, okay, dann gib mir doch mal von bei 5000 bis bei 7000 von den Daten nochmal den Hasch. Genau. Und zwar randommäßig auch. Nicht immer den gleichen natürlich, sondern ich geb dir einfach so einen bestimmten Bereich und du sollst mir genau davon den Hasch geben.
Aber dann brechen sie natürlich alle Dropbox-Klines.
Wieso? Können sie ja sagen, ab jetzt ist Umstellungszwang und zack, fertig. Bumm, zack, Return. So war das genau.
Na gut, ich mein, klar, die können ja immer noch sagen, kennen wir nicht, lad mal hoch. Genau.
Das könnten sie jetzt erstmal sagen, ist aber für sie natürlich schlecht, weil die haben auch Traffic-Kosten, wollen die natürlich verhindern. Sondern die werden ganz simpel dann noch so so ein random Hasch-Dings einführen. Müssen sie ja nicht mal immer machen, sondern nur manchmal halt.
Ja, wobei, das könntest du auch abfangen.
Wie denn?
Naja, ich meine, wenn die Datei an einer Stelle irgendwo liegt und du auch diese Requests... Dann brauchst du aber... Dann brauchst du schon die direkte... Das ist eine interessante Option.
Wenn du die Datei nicht hast, kannst du diesen Hasch nicht erstellen. Wenn du Zugriff auf diese Datei hast und an allen möglichen Stellen irgendwie dir die Bytes holen könntest, dann kannst du auch gleich die gesamte Datei von dort holen. Dann hast du sie sozusagen auch.
Du hättest dann den Treffik nicht mehr. Wie ist denn das überhaupt bei Dropbox? Wenn ich eine Datei bei mir lokal lösche, wird die dann auch bei S3 wirklich gelöscht?
Du hast ja ein Archiv bei Dropbox. Du kannst ja eh auf deine Historie zurückgreifen. Das ist ja ein Feature, dass du da auch ein Andelit machen kannst. Du kannst ins Webhinterface gehen und sagen, hier die Datei, die ich gelöscht habe, bitte wieder herstellen.
Also könnte ich das als unlimitiertes Archiv nutzen, indem ich eine Datei immer hochspiele. Also nehmen wir mal ein, ich habe 5 GB, oder was ist das Minimum? 2 GB, was man haben kann, glaube ich, bei Dropbox. Und ich möchte jetzt 5 GB hochspielen, indem ich einfach spiele 2 GB hoch, so, warte, bis die synchronisiert sind, lösche die direkt wieder, dann spiele ich die nächsten 2 GB hoch, lösche die wieder und dann, wenn ich das erste Gigabyte wieder habe, dann lösche ich, mache ich die leer und sage, hier machen wir einen Restore auf den Stand von damals.
Interessante These. Habe ich noch nicht darüber nachgedacht, wie sie sich da eigentlich verhalten und ob die alten Dateien in irgendeiner Form mit... Also die alten Dateien werden auf jeden Fall nicht mitgezählt. Wenn was gelöscht ist, ist es gelöscht. Dann gilt es nicht mehr als Teil deines Kontingents.
Ja, sonst auch totaler Schwachsinn. Weil ich kann mir nämlich vorstellen...
Aber totaler Schwachsinn ist ja so einiges. Zum Beispiel ist es totaler Schwachsinn, dass wenn ich dir eine Datei zur Verfügung stelle, dass wir die scheren, dass halt die Größe der Datei bei uns beiden mit rein zählt.
Nee, das ist glaube ich total wichtig, damit eben gerade nicht diese Peer-to-Peer-Netzwerke darüber aufgebaut werden.
Ja, aber irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, macht es das irgendwie für mich ein bisschen unbenutzbar?
Ich finde das total convenient eigentlich. Von der Einstellung her so dieses, guck mal, du hast hier 7,5 Gigabyte oder du hast hier 2 Gigabyte und damit und da nicht irgendwie, ja und wenn du dann und wenn mit dir jemanden schert, dann kostet das denen so und so viel und dich so und so viel, sondern zu sagen, was in deiner Dropbox drin ist, in deiner Dropbox drin und geht von deinem Quote ab. Find ich absolut nachvollziehbar.
Gut, aber dann hast du auf einmal deine eigenen Speichermengen nicht mehr im Griff und jemand anderes, der halt mehr hat, kann dir das eben so mal weglidossen.
Naja, du kannst es aber auch wieder löschen dann.
Ja, aber du musst es dann auch erstmal wieder löschen.
Mit Bösartigkeit kriegt man...
Ist aber ein Problem. Ist ein echtes Problem, weil es ja überhaupt nicht separiert ist von deinem Rest. Ja, also wenn er auch diesen Shared-Bereich nochmal separat halten würde, also wenn er sagt, deine eigenen Daten und das, was geshared ist, wird nochmal separat gezählt oder so. Dass du sozusagen so ein Share-Kontingent hast und ein Speicher-Kontingent. Das ein Speicher-Kontingent ist einfach die 50 Gigabyte, die du eingekauft hast oder die zwei Gigabyte, die du kriegst, die hast du einfach so. Und wenn du was shares, dann hast du noch ein Share-Kontingent. Du kannst halt sagen, ich habe zwei Gigabyte Speicher und ich habe 500 MB Share-Kontingent oder sowas.
Was? Dass das offensichtlich nicht mehr geht, das Dropship.
Dropship geht nicht mehr. Zumindest der Code. Blocks unknown. Ja, gut, keine Ahnung, was sie da... Also, dass dieses Beispiel, was dabei ist, funktioniert gerade nicht. Dann stimmt es vielleicht doch, dass es nicht geht. I don't know. Das kriegen wir jetzt... Können wir jetzt ein wenig hin. Also, irgendwas haben sie da... Irgendwas haben sie eingebaut. Vielleicht haben sie noch einen figuren Weg gefunden, außer den, den du da vorgeschlagen hast, Dennis. Zweites Problem, was sie jetzt mit dem aktuellen Client gelöst haben, ist, dass sie eben auch die Clients selbst nicht sich haben identifizieren lassen. Und du konntest halt, wenn du einfach die Konfigurationsdateien von einem Rechner wegkopierst, die auf den anderen bringen und damit dann einfach dich sofort, out of the box, auch wieder hin identifizieren. Falls hier das sozusagen abhanden gekommen ist, siehst du nicht, dass irgendjemand da auch noch drauf zugreift. Also du kannst nicht einfach verhindern, dass da noch ein weiterer Client dazukommt.
Was besonders gemein ist, selbst wenn du es wusstest, dass es jemand tut, konntest du nichts dagegen tun.
Was man jetzt dagegen tun kann, ist sich diese Version 1.0.20 oder so zu holen.
War das die Version gerade? Weil das Passwort da auch nicht mit drin ist. Ich hab mal bei Dropbox mein Passwort geändert und hab zu meiner großen Überraschung festgestellt, dass mich keiner meiner diversen Clients hat mich schon darauf eingestellt, was für ein Drama, überall das Passwort neu eingeben. Nö, musste ich ja nicht. Weil offensichtlich läuft die Authentifizierung.
Das war es nämlich. Und das wäre dann auch mit dem anderen Client. Du kannst den dann noch nicht mal ausschließen. Du hast gar keine Chance. Wenn der einmal authentifiziert ist, bleibt es einfach. Genau, das war das Problem.
Konntest du dir sagen, dass du auf deine Daten zugreifen kannst? Du konntest nichts dagegen tun.
Wer von uns beiden ist eigentlich fertiger? Du hast dich doch auch gestern irgendwie ins Nirwana gesoffen, oder?
Ja, ich war gestern mit Hörern trinken.
Mit Hörern?
Keine Schulddiskussion.
Und du?
Ich hab nicht gesoffen.
Du bist klar.
Nur geguckt.
Nehmen wir noch mal die Moderation, Dennis.
Moderation? Was haben wir denn hier? Scheiße, ich hab meinen Simple Note zugemacht. Moment, Moment, Moment. Und dann haben wir hier...
Ich hab noch ein hübsches Thema, was ich komplett vergessen habe. Und zwar, ich bin neulich das erste Mal in meinem Leben versehentlich in die Gründung eines V1 hineingeraten.
Ich wollte mir einen dramatischen Jingle einspielen.
Ist überhaupt nicht dramatisch, war eher putzig. Und zwar wurde der Unhosted e.V. gegründet.
Unhosted?
Unhosted. Und unhosted finde ich eine total grandiose Idee. Also die Adresse ist unhosted.org. Und da ich jetzt Gründungsmitglied bin und in den Statuten drin steht, dass wir unhosted schön bewerben sollen. Der will, also die Geschichte dahinter ist, dieser, ich weiß leider nicht, wie er heißt, ein Holländer, der wollte, der hat dieses, ein Kumpel von dem hatte die Idee zu diesem unhosted, was das ist, erkläre ich gleich noch. Und der hat dann so einen Prototypen entwickelt, hat ihn als Open Source freigegeben, hat gesagt, hier Welt, entwickle weiter. Und die Welt hat gesagt, wow, geil, nee, weiterentwickeln haben wir keinen Bock drauf. Und darum, er möchte jetzt gerne das Ding weiterentwickeln und hofft über Spenden, dass er sich über Spenden ein kleines Gehalt auszahlen kann, von dem man dann leben kann und das weiterentwickeln kann. Und unhosted vielleicht noch ein bisschen bewerben. Und das fand ich eine durchaus unterstützenswerte Idee. Weil unhosted ist so ein Ansatz, wie man im Web Daten und Applikationen voneinander trennen kann. Und zwar ist das so, wenn ihr einen Flickr-Account habt, dann oder nehmen wir mal ein Bildbearbeitungsprogramm im Netz. Dann spielt man da seine Bilder hoch und kann die Bilder da bearbeiten. Und ja, dann sind die aber auch gleichzeitig in der Applikation drin. Also dann ist Applikation und Datenspeicher das selbe. Das heißt, wenn der Pleite geht, der Anbieter, dann sind meine Daten auch flöten. Ich kann von nirgends woanders drauf zugreifen, wenn er jetzt nicht so gnädig ist und mir einen API anbietet und weiß darauf, was das für alles für Nachtrallade ist. Und darum gibt es dieses unhosted. Das heißt, die Applikation fragt nach. Ich würde dir jetzt gern auf deinen unhosted-Account zugreifen. Dann sagst du, gib mal die Adresse ein und erlaub mir das mal. Und dann kann sich dieses, nachdem du das zugelassen hast, kann sich diese Applikation auf deinem Server, hat die so einen kleinen Ordner und kann da ihre Daten drin abspeichern. Und in so einer JSON-Datei. Und ich kann diese Datei mir auch angucken und kann da gucken, was da für Daten drinne stehen. Das heißt, diese Applikation hat im Idealfall keinen Zugriff auf meine Daten. Und wenn der eine, wenn der pleite geht oder jemand anderes mit den Daten noch mehr anfangen kann, dann kann ich den auch darauf zugreifen lassen. Und hab sozusagen einen Datenspeicher im Netz.
Was ist, wenn unhosted-Pleite geht?
Das ist ein Open-Source-Projekt. Du kannst es auch auf deinem eigenen Server installieren. Die haben noch keine Domänen dafür im Augenblick, sondern ich hab das jetzt erstmal auf meinem eigenen Server installiert.
Man versucht sozusagen andere überhaupt zu zwingen, das zu benutzen.
Genau, es geht jetzt erstmal darum, diese...
Das API muss ja auch explizit unterstützt werden von denen.
Die muss explizit unterstützt werden. Das ist jetzt nicht trivial. Es geht ihm, glaube ich, sogar noch im nächsten Schritt darum, dass der Browser direkt eine JavaScript-AP bieten kann, mit dem die Daten dann einfach in den Browser gespeichert werden. Was sprich ich dagegen, dass der die dann vorrätig hält? Aus dem Gedanken heraus, das meiste sind eh JavaScript-Anwendungen. Die können ja sowieso komplett im Browser laufen. Ich finde das besonders toll, weil für ein kleines Projekt, was ich im Augenblick gerade mache, so eine Synchronisation zwischen Desktop und iPhone, wo es mir ja eigentlich total recht ist, wenn ich mich gar nicht um irgendeine scheiß Infrastruktur kümmern muss, um irgendeine scheiß Serverinfrastruktur. Und selbst wenn ich irgendwann mal keinen Bock mehr darauf habe, brauche ich keine Angst davor zu haben, dass die Nutzer dieses Apps, die da vielleicht sehr viel Geld für ausgegeben haben oder sehr wenig Geld ausgegeben haben, auf jeden Fall das weiter verwenden wollen, dass die dann im Regen stehen, sondern die können dann einfach zu einem anderen unhosted Provider wechseln und können da meine Apps weiter nutzen. Find ich klingt nachher total.
Das ist so ein Typ, der bei der FSFE arbeitet. Free Software Foundation in Europe.
Das könnte durchaus sein.
Michiel de Jong.
Genau.
Gibt's einen Link auf der unhosted.org-Seite, mit einem längeren Interview, wo er sich dazu äußert, dass ich jetzt aber nicht durchgelesen bekomme in dieser kurzen Zeit.
Ach Gott, die Seite sieht ja komplett neu aus. Als ich mal drauf war, sah ich ganz anders aus.
So schön webbig. Mit viel Leerzeichen, Space und hübschen Grafiken und so.
Ja, und da bin ich jetzt quasi...
Ich will auch mal Leute kennenlernen, die so hübsche Grafiken machen.
Der ist, den kann man bestimmt noch buchen. Ja, der ist auch einer der Mitarbeiter von unhosted und soll eben die hübschen Seiten machen.
Tja, Meter Ebene brauch ich auch dringend mal. Facelift.
Ja, wann stellst du die ersten Leute ein?
Tja, da bin ich leider noch ein paar Meter von entfernt, dass ich mir so etwas leisten könnte. Aber zu tun gäbe es mittlerweile was. Zumindest im gestalterischen Bereich.
Na ja, das hört sich an wie so eine Art Open ID nur für alle Daten an. Open ID ist ja eine reine Authentifizierung, oder? Und das ist, da kommen jetzt, also es ist mein, ja es ist ein bisschen, ich glaube, die haben so immer diese Wallet-Idee, also so dieses, man hat sein Portemonnaie und da werden die Daten drin gespeichert und dann kann man jemanden drauf zugreifen lassen, wenn man möchte und, ja. Der Verlauf der Hörerzahlen hat Ähnlichkeiten mit der, egal, ich liess besser keinen Chat mehr.
Ja, so ist das mit dieser Interaktivität, das kann manchmal ganz schön ablenken.
Ja, aber anhostet es auf jeden Fall, macht mal alle mit, ladet euch runter, installiert euch das auf eurem Server und spielt damit. Ist vor allen Dingen auch ein lustiges Gefühl, da gibt es so eine Seite, so My Favorite Sandwich, total dämliche Beispiel-Applikation. Aber dann hatte ich mir das installiert und hab das mit diesem My Favorite Sandwich ausprobiert, weil ich ja gucken musste, ob es auch klappt. Und dann hatte ich das irgendwann soweit. Und dann hab ich da auf einer komplett fremden Webseite was eingegeben und auf meinem Server haben sich Daten verändert. Das ist auf magischer Art schon ein ganz angenehmer Moment.
Man müsste mal vielleicht wieder was sagen zu dem Thema wie greife ich auf mein Konto zu. Das wird ja gerade ein echt heißes Thema jetzt, wo diese Banking-Webseiten in den nächsten Monaten vollständig unbenutzbar werden, weil man jetzt die ganze Zeit so ein albernes Gerät mit sich rumtragen muss. Also so ein PIN-Generator. Oder dein Telefon. Mit SMS.
Voll sicher aber.
Hör mal das letzte Chaos Radio Express, warum du das nicht machen willst.
Das habe ich mir angehört, da können wir gerne mal ein bisschen hier herumplagen. Ich dachte ja, ich hätte von GSM-Sicherheit schon so ein bisschen Ahnung und habe mir ja brav auf dem Kongress so einiges angehört, was da so alles geht und sowas, aber das war ja wirklich nochmal so...
Shocking News.
Also mit diesem Java auf der SIM-Karte drauf.
Das ist shocking. Das kann man ja auch alles gar nicht zusammenfassen, aber ja, also... Wir pluggen unsere eigenen Programme, das ist Chaos Radio Express, GSM Security, das mag jetzt erstmal so klingen, wie was, was man vielleicht nicht hören will, weil man jetzt nicht so ein Techie ist, aber es ist zwar technisch, aber es hat auf jeden Fall Sprengkraft.
Das war eben ein Horrorfilm, so Nein, geh nicht in den Raum da hinten rein! Nein, nutzt nicht diesen Dienst, nutzt nicht... Ah, ich nutze das ja selber, Mist.
Mit wem hast du den gemacht?
Mit Karsten Nohl. Und ja, das war ich ein schönes Gespräch, aber es sind dann wirklich doch eine ganze Menge Sachen gekommen, wo ich auch mit einem Fragezeichen dargestanden habe und mir dachte so, meine Güte, das kann doch wohl nicht euer Arzt sein. Chaosradio Express 179.
Ja, was willst du uns über...
Ja, ich bin jetzt wieder mal gerade dabei, Links rauszusuchen. Es gibt wohl demnächst da einen neuen Contender in diesem Markt der Programme, die versuchen, auf dein Konto zuzugreifen. Das neue Tool kommt hier auch aus Deutschland, was ja nicht besonders überrascht, weil wenn es um so was wie HBCI geht und so weiter, ist das ja dann doch immer noch eine sehr lokale Angelegenheit. Außerdem ist ja Deutschland so ein bisschen das Land des Homebankings. Tatsache ist, es gibt da so eine kleine App, die noch nicht sehr viel tut, muss man sagen. Aber das, was sie tut, tut sie ganz okay. Sie heißt MoneyMoney, moneymoneyapp.com. Und ist halt noch in Entwicklung 0.9.1. Und greift aber sehr solide auf Konto zu. Also wenn du da so mit deinen Zugangsdaten daherkommst und so weiter, das ist ja bei jeder Bank immer so ein bisschen anders. Sie verwenden wohl dasselbe Framework wie Pecunia, was ja so Open Source ist und frei und kostenlos, was mich immer ein bisschen ärgert, warum Software immer gleich kostenlos sein muss. Kann trotzdem was dafür bezahlen. Pecunia ist ein bisschen anstrengend im User-Interface, kann aber noch mehr als dieses MoneyMoney.
MoneyMoney in einem Wort?
Aber das iOutBank ist da schon immer noch reichlich weiter.
Eine iOutBank gibt es ja nicht für Mac.
Ah, für Mac meinst du jetzt? Ah, wir müssen doch wieder mehr über Mac reden.
Genau. Genau, für Mac ist das. Ja, okay, heißt ab.
Hast du noch nicht gesagt?
Stimmt.
MoneyMoney minus...
Ich bin heute auch ein bisschen durch, ich muss mich echt entschuldigen. Ich habe heute auch schon eine Sendung gemacht und gestern habe ich zu viel gesoffen.
Das sieht aber echt mal schnieke aus.
Ja, es ist sehr hübsch, aber es kann halt derzeit auch nur dein Konto abfragen, du kannst auch keine Überweisungen damit machen. Es hat so kleinere Schwächen im Detail, aber es sieht halt wirklich sehr neat aus und nervt einen eben nicht mit komplexen User-Interfaces.
Von daher kann das durchaus ein Start sein. Mach erst mal weiter.
Ja, so sehr viel mehr kann ich da gar nicht zu sagen. Ich habe das selber seit ein paar Tagen im Test.
Mir fällt gerade ein, was ist auf dem iPhone, was da noch fehlt. Ich habe ja AI Outbank. Was man ganz simpel bräuchte, ist eine App, die meinen Kontostand so anzeigt, wie das Stock-App von Apple, die die Stocks anzeigt, die Aktien. Dass du gleich so einen Grafen hast über die Zeit.
Das macht man niemals. Das ist da drin. Sie haben so eine Visualisierung. Das sieht auch sehr hübsch aus. Von deinem Kontoverlauf mit so einem Bas.
Kannst du gleich sehen, hier war Jahresanfang, da war richtig teuer.
Aber es gibt halt noch keine Möglichkeit. Du kannst nicht sortieren nach bestimmten Kategorien, Überweisungen, Datum oder so was. Du hast nicht da so, wie man das normalerweise von so einer Macintosh-Applikation erwarten würde. Weißt du, zahlen und spalten und dann klickst du oben drauf. Dann ist es danach sortiert. Das ist halt einfach nur nach Zeit sortiert und sieht irgendwie hübsch aus. Du kannst da keine Einträge markieren und Copy und Paste, also Paste sowieso nicht, aber Copy geht halt auch nicht. Du kriegst auch nichts raus aus diesem Tool. Es hat keinen Import, keinen Export.
Also es hat schon noch ein bisschen zu tun.
Da ist definitiv noch was zu tun, aber es ist zumindest schon mal gut zu sehen, dass da jetzt ein bisschen Bewegung reinkommt. Ich hab auch immer noch dieses Gerücht im Ohr, dass die Jungs, die iOutbank für das iPhone machen, auch an einer Macintosh-Applikation schrauben.
Na wahrscheinlich. Wenn sie schlau sind, tun sie das.
Wenn sie schlau sind, aber ich weiß nicht, wie schlau sie sind.
Ich glaube, ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass die diesen, I don't know, diesen iPhone-Markt gerade mal so richtig schön nochmal, ich meine, kann man sich auch gut drauf konzentrieren.
Ja, aber jetzt mit dem Mac-Appstore ist es halt auch da.
Aber es ist interessant, jetzt die Programmewelle schwappt ja zum iPhone zurück auf den Mac. Also das heißt sozusagen, erst Angry Birds auf dem Phone und dann auf dem Rechner. Und also, die haben da schon einen guten, also Apple hat da schon einen guten Vorsprung hingelegt. Also es ist ja doppelseitige Synergie-Effekte.
Was ich da jetzt nochmal zu Backing-Apps empfehlen kann, ist Saldo Mart. Ist nicht schön.
Es ist nicht schön.
Aber es ist unglaublich praktisch. Man kann sich in Kontostand...
Schau mal, da. Juni 2011 soll iOutbank...
Menschenskinder, das kauf ich mal kurz. Die sollen hier mal Beta-Raisieren.
Kaum haben wir hier eine Idee, setzen die das auch schon gleich im Folgemonat um.
Wie haben die so schnell in FH2 geschrieben?
Dieses Saldo Mart ist... Die haben die Folge schon vorausgehört und haben dann schon vorher nicht angefangen, daran zu entwickeln. Das wird's doch sein. Dieses Saldo Mart ist halt... Es zeigt einem in der Menüleiste den Kontostand an. Wenn man das nicht möchte, weil man, wir haben auch Kollegen oder irgendwelche anderen Leute, denen man jetzt nicht dringend seinen Kontostand auf die Nase binden möchte, einem über die Schultern gucken, dann kann man sich da auch einfach so ein kleines Euro-Zeichen anzeigen lassen, wo dann aber immerhin steht, wie viele Abgänge und Draufgänge auf dem Konto gibt es. Draufgänge? Na ja, hier Dings. Einzahlung auf dem Konto es gibt. Und das ist echt schick, das macht echt eine Menge her. Und man kann da auch filtern und alles. Wie gesagt, alles unglaublich hässlich, unglaublich furchtbar. Die haben sogar in diesem Saldomat ein kleiner RSS-Server, also ein kleiner Web-Server eingebaut, mit dem man sich dann in seinen RSS-Rädern rein seiner aktuellen Kontobewegung abonnieren kann. Also die haben tausende Exportformate und Importformate und weiß der Teufel was alles. Auch so für diese ganzen Bank X und so diese ganzen hässlichen Programme. Ja, aber wenn man so einfach seinen Kontostand schnell im Blick haben möchte, ist das automat großartig.
Übrigens jetzt, wo ich es gerade nochmal check, bei Pecunia gibt es auch eine neue Version, eine 03 Beta. Also man muss es nur mal kurz erwähnen und dann kommt dann auch gleich Bewegung ins Spiel. Aber Juni 2011, Outback für Mac OS X, also das könnte natürlich auch sehr interessant werden, weil was da ganz gut funktioniert, ist einfach alles. Die haben es geschafft nach so einer etwas hakeligen ersten Version wirklich ein extrem solides und brauchbares User Interface hinzubekommen und das kommuniziert auch mit den Banken ohne Zicken. Und das macht einfach Spaß. Ich bin gespannt, ob sie es schaffen, da auch das Feature Set auf den Mac zu transferieren.
Na ja, die machen mehr als nur HBCI.
Die haben ziemlich viel Spezialkode für die ganzen verschiedenen Banken drin, damit die mit allen klarkommen. Sieht man ja an den Updates immer, dass sie wieder jetzt mit der Bank funktionieren, jetzt wieder auch mit der Bank und so.
Naja, ich hab zum Beispiel also mit Money Money unten mit dem Pecunia, was mich nicht wundert, weil die auf demselben Framework basieren. Ich hab zum Beispiel mit, was war das? Comdirect, ein Comdirect Konto. Ging irgendwie von hinten und vorne nicht, was iOutbank problemlos hinbekommen hat.
Bei iOutbank krieg ich auch zum Beispiel bei der DKB bin ich, hab ich ein Konto und hab da, da krieg ich über Saldomat nur mein Girokonto, während ich über iOutbank auch mein Kreditkartenkonto sehen kann. Und da hab ich mal bei den Saldomat-Menschen angefragt. Bei welcher Bank?
Ah, beim Sparkass hab ich das nicht hinbekommen.
Und da hab ich nämlich mal bei den Saldomat-Leuten angefragt, hey, wie sieht denn das aus, wieso kann das iOutbank und wieso könnt ihr das nicht? Und dann, ja, die nehmen ja so eigene, also die kamen auch ein bisschen pissige Antwort zurück, aber halt so, ja, die nehmen kein HBCI, sondern die surfen die Seite quasi ab.
Wer macht das?
iOutbank.
Sie surfen die Seite ab?
Ich weiß nicht, wie sie das machen, aber wahrscheinlich werden sie den HTML-Code abscannen, oder?
Wieso nicht?
Das ist ja super labil, ich meine, erinnert da irgendwie einer in einer Webseite, dann bricht das alles.
Also hier meint jedenfalls, im Chat meint gerade jemand, dass sie in tatsächlich Gorgos, dass sie den HTML-Code pasen. Das ist doch auch das, was ich mehrfach gehört habe.
Gute Güte, das finde ich eigentlich so toll. Ach, die Welt ist schlecht, aber diese Banken, die bemühen sich auch wirklich nicht, das muss man mal sagen. Die haben so viel Geld, so viel Geld und dann...
Darum haben sie sich nicht nötig, sich zu bemühen.
Aber bei diesem Saldomat hat sich ein bisschen was getan. Das sieht nicht mehr ganz so dreckig aus.
Sieht nicht mehr.
Auf den ersten Blick so.
Ich weiß nicht, wie dreckig das früher aussah.
Ich fand's schlimm. Aber ich mag auch Programme, die sich nur im Menü befinden. Das ist einfach... Ich brauch ein großes Fenster. Ich will da suchen, ich will da sortieren.
Du kannst da auch ein Fenster aufmachen. Da unten ist so ein Filter-Button und dann geht ein eigenes Fenster auf.
Aber ist das dann auch mal so ein Programm mit eigenem Menü?
Das weiß ich jetzt gerade nicht.
Was hält dir davon ab, so was zu tun? Das verstehe ich nicht.
Ich weiß, es kann durchaus sein, dass in dem Moment dann das Doc Icon gestartet wird. Ich habe das Icon auch schon im Doc gesehen von diesem Saldomat.
Ich werde das noch mal ausprobieren. Vielleicht ist das ja toll.
Saldomat macht auf jeden Fall Spaß.
Version 1.6.
Geht jetzt an den Start. Warum können sie nicht einfach mal ein Datum dazu schreiben, dass man später noch weiß, wann jetzt war?
Weil das Internet doch echt Zeit ist.
Also ich bin gespannt. Im Juli werden wir mal den Sieger kühren von diesem Rennen. Ich denke, wer im Juli am meisten strahlt, hat einfach unsere Unterstützung verdient.
Ach, wenn dann ein I-Out-Bank draußen ist, ja?
Der Flash meint, er arbeitet auch an der Banking-API. Das wäre ganz furchtbar.
Er hat mal fertig bis Juli.
Dieses HBCI ist auch extrem fehleranfällig. Dieses Saldomat, wie oft das zwischendurch einfach mal keine Verbindung irgendwo hinkriegt, weil da gerade mal wieder ein Server bei der Postbank oder so rumzickt. So eine schöne Rest-API, ich glaube, die würde dir dann schon echt...
Ich brauche mir noch dieses Kommunikationslog bei Pecunia anzuschauen, da weiß man schon, dass das ganz furchtbar ist.
Ja, was die da so hin-
Das ist eine gesprächige Scheiße.
Bestimmt alles 8xXML oder so was?
Ja, da merkst du einfach, dass diese Leute keinen Internet-Hintergrund haben.
Da merkst du, dass sich da Leute wahrscheinlich dreieinhalb Jahre lang irgendwie regelmäßig getroffen haben.
Unser Komitees.
Das gigantische Protokoll aller Zeiten definiert haben. Wir wollen Kontostände abfragen. Oh mein Gott, das darf nicht einfach sein.
Kommen wir zu den wichtigen Ups. Also, was ich euch empfehlen kann. Esst ihr gerne Eier?
Was heißt Essen? Nee, ich mag Rührei lieber.
Und warum?
Weil die Eier nie so werden, wie du es dir wünschst?
Oder was? Nee, weil bei Shake-Rüh-Eier da ja auch ein bisschen Fett und Öl mit bei ist, weißt schon.
Ich finde Rüh-Eier auch besser.
Weil das ist nämlich ein Geschmacksverstärker mit dem Fett und dem Öl. Und so gekochte Eier, die sind immer so...
Ich mag so Rüh-Eier mit so ein bisschen Käse noch so reingeschmückt.
Ich wollte hier keinen Kochkurs starten. Auf jeden Fall kann ich sehr empfehlen...
Egg-Timer.
Fuse Interfaces ist ein bisschen... Also es sieht so ein bisschen komisch aus, aber die Features sind cool. Also du kannst halt wirklich diese abstarten. Nimmst dein Ei. Gibst dann erstmal die Ei-Größe an. Du kannst das Ei auf das iPhone legen, quasi auf so ein raster Maß.
Du legst das Ei auf das iPhone.
Du legst das Ei auf das iPhone, genau. Damit wird das iPhone das erste Mal auf seinem iPhone. Für Straußeneier dann. Und gibst also wirklich so die Größe deines Eis an. Also du kannst hier wirklich so mit dem Finger da die Größe des Eis so bestimmen und das Ei wächst dann hier so auch mit der Bewegung sozusagen so mit. Dann gibst du noch die Höhe an. Du kannst halt irgendwie Location machen und der nimmt halt die von der Location.
Das fährt doch hoffentlich selber raus, oder?
Der guckt ja in die Konsolidated DB rein.
Ja.
Und guckt, wie hoch es vor einem Jahr war. Und du kannst also die Höhe angeben. Also mit anderen Worten, der normale Luftdruck wird auch berücksichtigt. Dann gibst du noch die Eittemperatur an. Genau, also ob das Ding aus dem Kühlschrank kommt oder ob es irgendwie Raumtemperatur hat oder irgendwo so dazwischen. Dann sagst du halt, was du so für ein Ei, wie du es gerne hättest. Ja, und dann musst du halt die Eier ins kalte Wasser legen. Wichtig. Und dann voll Feuer machen. Ins kalte Wasser. Und dann drückst du Start ab dem Moment, wo es kocht. Also so diese Vorglühphase ist da irgendwie mit eingerechnet. Ich freu mich mal, warum das jetzt unbedingt so sein muss.
Damit es noch ein Stück schneller geht, weil der kannst du ja jetzt berechnen.
Na gut, man könnte ja auch sagen, bring es zum Kochen, tu die Eier dann rein und so.
Ja, aber dann dauert es ja ein bisschen länger.
Die Frage...
Na, weil das Ei hat jetzt vorher schon Energie aufgenommen. Deswegen geht es ein bisschen flotter.
Ja gut, wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall so funktioniert es. Und dann sagt dir der Timer halt auch schon vorher so Bescheid. Also nicht erst, wenn es soweit ist, sondern wenn es sozusagen bald soweit ist. Und dann kannst du eben auch selber auch noch ein bisschen länger kochen lassen. Und er zeigt dir immer an, wie dein Ei jetzt gerade so ist. Also ob es weich ist, ob es schon so fest mit ein bisschen weich oder schon richtig fest ist. Und ich habe es ausprobiert und es funktioniert. Es ist wirklich unglaublich.
Und das gleiche App gibt es auch für Stakes.
Und wie heißt das? Stake Timer?
Kann das sein, weiß nicht. Ich habe es nicht runtergeladen, aber da war auch so... Die Größe an und die Dicke und alles.
Da klatscht so dein Stake aufs iPad drauf, dann kannst du mit dem Finger nachzahlen die grobe Form. Ich glaube natürlich auch...
Und die werben damit, dass es mit dem App schneller geht, oder wie? Oder was ist da auch das Spezielle?
Das ist einfach Hinhaut.
Nicht mehr 4 Minuten für ein weiches Ei, sondern 3 Minuten und 7 Sekunden oder wie? Weil es eben schon vor dem Kochen im Wasser liegt. Weil das war ja auch nochmal so ein Werbe-Dings, dass man sagt, wir machen unsere Weicheier dadurch schon in 3 Minuten.
Also diese Vorhersage, wann das Ei wirklich genau so ist, wie du es haben möchtest, die ist so einfach nicht. Da haben sich schon einige Leute die Zähne dran ausgebrochen.
Dafür braucht man jetzt auch das weiße iPhone, damit es so weiß ist wie das Ei.
Genau, dann kannst du das auch gleich da drauf verzehren. So ein Scheiben schneiden und so.
Das könnte man auch machen, indem man einfach diese WLAN-Funktion einschaltet.
Ja, Stake-Timer heißt es tatsächlich anscheinend.
Habe ich aber nicht getestet.
Ich kann auch ein anderes Timer-App empfehlen. Das ist jetzt für den eher Menschen, der die exakte Zeit braucht. Das ist so ein bisschen wie diese Timer-Funktion, die man auch so normalerweise am iPhone drin hat, die aber dummerweise ja nur einen Timer drin hat, den man dann jeweils einstellen muss. Hier kann man sich einfach so wie im Wecker-App beliebige viele Timer anlegen, die dann runterzählen und draufzählen. Sieht sehr, sehr hübsch aus. Du, D-U-E. Er hat noch eine Erinnerungsfunktion, was ich ganz praktisch finde, wo man sagen kann, also das ist die Timer-Funktion, die sieht so aus. Das können jetzt die Hörer sich auch gut vorstellen, wie Tim gerade guckt. Und er hat eine Erinnerungsfunktion, was ich ganz angenehm finde, dass man auch sagen kann, du erinnere mich mal in vier Tagen an irgendwas, ohne jetzt gleich einen Kalendereintrag anlegen zu müssen, was ja doch öfters mal ganz schön nervt. Er hat ein Logbuch darüber. Achso, man kann bestimmte Ereignisse recyceln. Also wenn man irgendwie einmal jetzt gesagt hat, erinnere ich mal einer Stunde, dann kann man morgen sich auch wieder eine Stunde dran erinnern lassen. So für wiederkehrende Aufgaben ist das ganz praktisch. Sieht ganz niedlich aus, kostet irgendwie, ich glaube 79 Cent den üblichen Spaß und ist durchaus das Geld wert. Und... Ach so, was ich nochmal kurz erzählen wollte, ich war am Wochenende in Italien. Und...
Mal eben.
Mal eben, zu einer Hochzeit, nicht zu meiner, war sehr, sehr gediegen. Und jetzt hatten wir natürlich das Problem, dass wir da keine Daten hatten, beziehungsweise, dass die an Schweine Geld kosten. Da hatte ich mich vorher mal schluss... Internetdatenverkehr.
Du hattest kein Internet, wolltest du sagen.
Ich hätte mein Internet vorher runterladen können. Ich hatte keinen Datenverkehr. Und darum sind wir dann in Mailand, wo ich mich dann mit Navigon zum nächsten SIM-Kartenverkaufsladen steuern lassen. Navigon ist auch wirklich ein schreckliches Programm. Wirklich?
Aber kennst du einfach bei Google Maps hier irgendwie...
Ich hatte doch keine Daten.
Und wo hast du denn Navigon herbekommen?
Navigon hat die Daten ja offline. Jaja, Navigon hatte ich schon vorher. Und als Auto-Navi ist es vielleicht ganz praktisch. Aber wenn man einfach mal so in der Stadt rumlaufen möchte, also diesen Google Maps-Modus, dass die das nicht schaffen, den mal einzubauen, das verstehe ich einfach nicht. Die haben die Daten da, die bräuchten einfach nur etwas anderen Views zu machen und schon könnten die perfekt so für mich in der Stadt rummachen. Was die davon abhält. Oh Gott, wir müssen jetzt hier noch das...
Was funktioniert da nicht? Ich meine, du kannst das doch einfach vor deine Nase halten und dann gehst du durch die Gegend.
Du hast keine vernünftige Übersichtskarte von oben drauf. Du kannst dir nicht einen Überblick in der Stadt verschaffen, sondern du hast im Wesentlichen Abwandlung von diesem 3D-Modus, ich fahre jetzt gerade in die Richtung und da hinten sind die und die Straßen. Du kannst dich da natürlich so dämlich rumnavigieren lassen.
Du meinst, das funktioniert erst ab 30 Stundenkilometer richtig?
Und da jemand per Twitter gefragt hatte, was man in Italien empfehlen kann, womit ich jetzt sehr glücklich war, das war Wind, heißen die. Wind, keine Ahnung, wie das ausgesprochen wird. Das ist besonders lustig, weil wenn man nur Edge hat, was ein paar Mal vorkam, dann steht...
So wie Winde.
Wenn man da Edge hatte, dann stand da oben Winde oben in der Leiste.
Wenn man Edge hatte?
Wenn ich Edge habe, dann steht statt 3G da oben E, und dann stand da Wind für den Provider und dahinter das E. Und während ich vorher die ganze Zeit per Default... Wind ist ein Netz?
Ja, ist der Provider.
Und wenn da richtig starke Böen waren, dann stand da Max-Winde.
Aber der Default Provider für Italien bei O2 ist Tim. Und dann bin ich sozusagen von Tim auf Winde gewechselt. Und auf jeden Fall war das... das war echt sehr entspannt. Also das war ein Laden relativ schnell gefunden. Eine SIM-Karte, sogar eine Mikro-SIM-Karte für einen Zehner gekauft, kurz Ausweis vorgelegt, auch in bar bezahlt, dann gibt's da so...
Die waren nicht anonym?
Du musst immer einen Ausweis vorlegen, wenn du eine SIM-Karte kaufst. Also ich hab's bisher noch nie anders erlebt.
Hast du deine Karte bei Luigi gekauft?
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich da dieselben Tarife gekriegt hätte. Auf jeden Fall 3 Euro hat das gekostet, so eine Woche lang 250 Megabyte.
Für 3 Euro?
Find ich okay.
Ist ja billiger als hier.
Naja, hier kriegste bei Simio auch für einen Zehner, kriegste einen Gigabyte für einen Monat oder so.
Ich bin bei O2 und zahl 10 Euro für 200 MB.
Das ist aber auch ein total alter Vertrag, oder?
Ja, ich könnte auf 300 upgraden und so. Den kriegt man ja inzwischen auch für die 10 Euro. Aber am Ende sind es 10 Euro, die ich jeden Monat zahle.
Na ja, 10 Euro zahlst du also einen Monat mit einem Gigabyte. Das kostet bei diesem Wind auch einen Zehner.
Ich hab aber nur 300 MB. Und zwar nicht im Ausland, sondern hier.
Ja, siehste. Geh mal zu Simio oder zu... Ich glaub, bei O2 gibt es mittlerweile... Nee, gibt es nicht mehr.
Na, die können es deswegen so billig machen, weil die es halt als Zusatzding anbieten. Also damit Kunden überhaupt erst mal grundsätzlich anlocken. Die bei O2 haben mich ja schon. Und ich will das ja auf meine Nummer draufhaben. Und deswegen kostet das natürlich ein bisschen was.
Bei Wind meinste oder bei...
Nee, bei O2. Wo ich bin. Pass auf, ich hab einen Mobilfunkvertrag schon mit Nummer und will ja meine Daten auf diese SIM mit draufhaben. Nicht extra. Eine extra Karte bei Simio.
Ach so, bei Simio könnte das jetzt auch dein Telefonnummer theoretisch zu Simio portieren?
Ja gut, aber dann krieg ich auch wieder einen anderen Telefoniervertrag, der wieder andere Kosten hat eventuell.
Ja, aber die sind ziemlich günstig. Was ich aber... Haben wir jemals hier über dieses ZipGate 1 gesprochen?
Nee, oder?
Ich glaube ja.
Über ZipGate 1? Weil das finde ich ja eigentlich so eine total geile Idee für genau solche Fälle. Da kann man ja... Bei ZipGate 1 kann man sich... Ist das glaube ich noch eine Beta-Phase?
Warte mal kurz. Dieses...
also du hast dann Wind genommen.
Genau.
Und das war okay?
Das war okay. Ich hatte überall guten Empfang.
Es gibt ja immer wieder diese Frage mit was holt man sich in welchem Land. Genau. Da möchte ich nochmal auf was hinweisen, was einem weiterhelfen könnte, nämlich das Pay as you go SIM with Data Wiki.
Genau, da habe ich das nämlich auch.
Achso, ok, dann sollte man das vielleicht auch nochmal erwähnen.
Und dann habe ich nochmal gucken...
paygsimwithdata.wikia.com Das ist halt das Wiki, wo man so nachschlägt. Und da wird es dann für jedes Land...
Wenn ich das mal brauche, dann gebe ich eigentlich immer bei Google nur ein Wiki, SIM, prepaid, data und das finde ich dann immer gleich.
Ja gut.
Das ist, ich hab mir das...
Zipgate.
Zipgate, genau. Zipgate One ist so ein Dienst, du kriegst von denen eine Handynummer und kostet dich nix. Und diese Handynummer kannst du weiterleiten auf ein anderes Handy, auf Festnetz und auf Skype, so du möchtest. Oder auf was auch immer du davon möchtest. Und die machen nichts weiter als deinen Anruf weiterleiten. Also wenn dich jemand unter der Telefonnummer anruft, dann klingelt dein Handy oder klingelt deine Festnetznummer. Das heißt, was O2 nicht auf die Reihe kriegt, nämlich wo ich in meiner Wohnung einfach keinen Empfang habe, dass ich sagen kann, er leitet doch den Anruf auf mein Festnetz weiter, mit dem ich wenigstens erreichbar bin, das machen die. Zur Not eben, wie gesagt, auch auf Skype. Man kann unter der Nummer auch SMS empfangen. Ich glaube auch versenden.
Also sie leiten das auch an Skype weiter, auch wenn man keine Skype-Telefonnummer hat?
Du gibst deinen Skype-Username an und dann klingelt dein Skype.
Also man braucht da nicht so einen Skype-Innen?
Nee, nee, braucht man gar nichts mehr.
Du sagst aber, du hast zu Hause keinen Empfang, musst halt, wenn du zu Hause ankommst, umschalten und wenn du gehst, musst du wieder zurückschalten.
Nee, nee, es klingeln einfach alle Telefonnummern, die du magst.
Ach so, beide?
Ja, die klingeln gleichzeitig und wer zuerst rangeht, hat halt Glück gehabt. Dann haben sie noch ein iPhone-App, was ganz furchtbar ist im Augenblick. Also das ist echt ganz grauselig. Aber ich finde so diese Option, dass ich da eine Telefonnummer kriege. Ach so, sie haben auch einen Anrufbeantworter mit Spracherkennung, die aber eher lächerlich ist. Aber was ich ganz cool daran finde, ist diese Tatsache, du kriegst eine Telefonnummer und je nachdem, wer gerade dein billigster Provider ist und du hast keinen Bock, jetzt nehmen wir mal an so Republika-Woche und ich hab bei O2 gar keinen Empfang die ganze Woche über und das nervt doch alles. Und ich will mal rasch eine andere SIM-Card in mein Telefon reinpacken, dann bin ich ja wieder telefonisch nicht erreichbar. Das Problem hat man sich dann relativ, hat man sich dann schön leicht von der Backe geschafft. Wenn die jetzt noch Telefonnummernportierungen könnten, dann würde ich da sofort meine O2-Nummer rüberschieben und dann könnte ich bei Bedarf wechseln. Was ich sehr toll fände. Ja, das hoffe ich auch.
Es wird hier noch angemerkt über die üblich verdächtigen Kanäle. Dass es ja auch noch bei dieser Banking-Geschichte auch noch BankX gibt. Eine Software, die auf ihrer Webseite behauptet, man müsse sie Bank10 aussprechen.
Das habe ich irgendwann mal gekauft. Vor ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz langer Zeit. Und das wird irgendwie von Application Systems Heidelberg vertrieben. Und ich musste das unbedingt damals, gab's das nur mit CD-Höhle dazu, keine Ahnung warum. Ich konnte mir das nicht einfach runterladen. Ich musste dazu eine hässliche Packung nehmen. Und wie war das damals bei der Postbank? Zuerst konnte ich keine Überweisung mit durchführen. Genau, weil sie M-TAN nicht konnten. Und ich halt immer nur M-TAN verwendet habe. Und dann irgendwann konnten sie auch keine Abfragen mehr durchführen, weil die Postbank irgendwie ihre Abfragen umgestellt haben. Und die haben so quasi eine Mail geschickt. Ja, nee, geht halt nicht mehr. Seitdem sind die für mich echt...
Also ist wohl weiterentwickelt worden. Leute behaupten, man könne das hier irgendwie benutzen. Find's bloß irgendwie alles ein bisschen merkwürdig. Es gibt da ein Bank X, dann gibt es ein Bank X Professional. Mit so...
Und die haben ja one password auf ihrer Seite, das ist aber nicht von denen, oder?
Nee, kann sein, dass die so einen deutschen Vertrieb dafür machen.
Die vertreiben einfach alles mögliche, diese ASH-Leute. Das ist alles etwas merkwürdig.
Die haben damals auch real basic Vertrieb und es sieht ganz unerträglich aus.
Klicken sie hier, um das Update online anzufordern. Da muss man ein Formular eingeben. Ja genau, das sind die mit dem Formular. Ja, um dein Update zu holen. Dann muss ein Formular mit dein Daten eingeben, um dann die neue Version zu bekommen.
So.
Schon so ein bisschen merkwürdig.
Also dieses Application Systems Heidelberg, oh Gott, das ist echt auch eine furchtbare Webseite, die die haben.
Die verzogenen Kinder von Mobamex sind unzufrieden. Es macht es einem nicht einfach, das mal eben zu testen. Liebe Anwendungsprogrammierer, Webseiten müssen dazu einladen, dass man schnell Software getestet bekommt.
Aber ich glaube, die basieren so darauf, ich glaube, Application Systems Heidelberg, die nehmen bestehende Software und packen die dann in Kisten. Für die Leute, die darauf immer noch stehen. Das ist so, glaube ich, der Geschäftsmodell. Und damals konnte man auch Real Basic nur über die kaufen.
Simple Note, ey, du bist ja so ein Versprechen, aber trotzdem so ein Schmerz. Ich muss mich noch mal ein bisschen aufregen hier über Simple Note, das geht einfach alles überhaupt nicht. Ich verwende ja immer noch dieses Just Notes, was irgendwie mal ganz vielversprechend anfing, aber jetzt auch schon seit Ewigkeiten keine Updates mehr geliefert hat und mich einfach nur noch nervt. Das ist echt ein bisschen anstrengend. Wieso gibt es keinen ordentlichen McIntosh-Kline für Simple Note? Ich meine, das ist an sich ein ganz ordentlicher Dienst, aber es gibt einfach nichts ordentliches. Es gab mal dieses Notational Velocity am Anfang, was aber irgendwie nicht weiterentwickelt wird. Mal gucken, vielleicht hat sich das ja auch wieder geändert.
Genau, die sollten mal einfach schön...
Was behaupte, was nicht stimmt.
Schön klein für einen Desktop schreiben. Wobei, irgendwie muss ich sagen, diese ganzen Features, also dieses Sharing-Feature ist ja auch irgendwie ein bisschen merkwürdig implementiert. Oder, dass man die E-Mail... Also bei Simple Note kann man mittlerweile Dinge auch sharen mit anderen Leuten, indem man ihre E-Mail-Adresse in das Tag-Feld eingibt, was ich auch total albern finde. Warum soll ich einfach einen Sharing-Button haben, hier mit denen und den Leuten teilen und fertig ist? Nee, muss das ins Tags-Feld rein.
Ja, das finde ich auch ein bisschen merkwürdig. Aber es gab hier tatsächlich Updates wieder. Guck an, bei Notation Evil. Ich dachte, das wäre eingeschlafen. Aber es war auch eingeschlafen.
War dieses Just-Note nicht eine inoffizielle Weiterentwicklung?
Ein Jahr hat sich da nichts getan. Und jetzt sind sie nach einem Jahr auf Version 2.0 Beta 4 und dann nochmal zwei Monate später auf 2.0 Beta 5. Also vertrauenserweckend finde ich sowas ja nicht. Okay, kann ich vielleicht nochmal auswählen.
Was war denn vorher eine Version?
2.0 Beta 3. Ja, auch so Software, die aus ihrem Beta-Zustand nicht herauskommt. Die erste 2.0 Beta ist von 2009. Warum Beta? Warum released ihr nicht einfach? Wieso nennt ihr das nicht einfach Version sowieso? Und dann ist es fertig. Entweder ist es Beta, dann muss es schnell ersetzt werden oder es ist nicht Beta. Dann äh...
Na, weil die Beta gut genug funktioniert und alle froh sind und keiner mehr Bock hat weiterzumachen.
Ja, aber was soll das heißen?
Beta?
Wo ist denn diese Beta? Ich find hier gar keinen Download-Link.
Mach ich irgendwas falsch?
Ah ja, genau, ich klicke auf das falsche Teil. Gut, ich werd das nochmal ausprobieren. Also mein Problem, was ich mit den Just Notes habe, ist, dass immer wenn es synkt, scrollt es wieder an den Anfang des Textes. Ja, indem du die ganze Zeit irgendwie arbeitest und dann immer wenn er zwischendurch synkt, schmeißt er dich irgendwie aus deiner aktuellen Editierposition raus und landest wieder oben. Macht mich wirklich total verrückt.
Ach du hast doch mal so von Sinks geschwärmt, dass die jetzt ein Cloudsyncing haben, ne?
Nein, ich habe nicht, ich habe gesagt, ich würde gerne von ihnen schwärmen, wenn sie mal endlich einen hätten.
Ja, hast du schon einen Beta-Account?
Nein, ich hab mich aber da eingetragen und behaupten, dass sie jetzt wohl, zumindest für die MEC-Seite, da mit irgendwas an den Start kommen. Andererseits habe ich mich vor einer Woche wieder dazu aufgeschwungen, meine bereits mehr oder weniger vollständig erworbene Sammlung von OmniFocus dann doch mal wieder mehr in den Mittelpunkt meines Interesses zu...
In den Focus zu schieben, heißt es.
Mit bisher noch nicht so richtig großem Erfolg, aber zumindest fange ich mal wieder an, meine Todos zu sammeln. Spannend, wie lang das hält.
Worüber synkt OmniFocus?
Bitte?
Über WebDAV-Server. Das kann zum Beispiel dein Mobile-Me sein. Also wenn du Mobile-Me hast, dann sagst du aber, hier in dem Mobile-Me, zack, und dann macht er das da drüber.
Oder wenn man einen eigenen Server hat, kann das auch der eigene Server sein.
Ja, es gibt auch noch weitere Optionen. Lass mich mal kurz gucken. Wenn ich so richtig eingehe und mich beschäftige, über Bonjour, über OmniSync. Also es gibt jetzt auch diese OmniSync-Server, was mich ja noch ein bisschen hoffen lässt. Wenn es jetzt etwas gibt, was OmniSync heißt, und man hat da einen Account.
Vielleicht, vielleicht...
Hat das was mit Syncing zu tun?
Könnte es ja sein, vielleicht, dass irgendwann mal auch OmniOutliner gesynced wird.
Ja, aber dieses Syncing gehört eigentlich eher langsam mal endlich ins Betriebssystem rein, ne?
Das gehört vor allem hier auf meinen Desktop. Egal, wer es mir implementiert. Ich will endlich Outline gesynced.
Ich werde es überall haben.
Warum gibt es das nicht? Wie oft soll ich mich noch darüber aufregen? Ich verstehe das nicht. Naja, wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall, das funktioniert soweit ganz gut. Ich finde, OmniFocus kommt doch schon noch sehr komplex daher. Man muss das wirklich erlernen. Man muss sich das richtig anschauen. Man muss so richtig diese Screencasts da durchgehen und man muss da mehrere AHA-Effekte haben. Und vielleicht muss man auch noch diese komischen GTD-Bücher lesen, um dann wirklich zu begreifen, was man da eigentlich tut. Und dann hat man vielleicht wirklich eine Chance. Aber es springt für mich nicht so ins Gesicht. Also ich muss zumindest bisher noch mehr drüber nachdenken. Und das ist eigentlich das, was ich an Things so mochte, dass das so einen interessanten Schnitt gemacht hat in der Reduktion. Sie sind nicht über einen bestimmten Komplexitätsgrad hinausgegangen. Und das mag für mich und vielleicht für viele andere auch so der Punkt gewesen sein, wo ich sage, es hilft, wenn das einfacher zu verstehen ist. Auch wenn ich so komplexere Tasks damit nicht abbilden kann. Andererseits bin ich auch ein Freund von komplexen Task-Formulierungen. Aber es ist halt immer dieses Problem mit diesen To-Do-Applikationen, dass du dann eben viel Zeit darauf verwendest, deine To-Do's zu aufzuschreiben und so in so eine hierarchische Struktur zu bringen. Und die findest du dann so toll, dass du dich die ganze Zeit davor setzt und sie anstaunst, aber bloß nicht irgendwas davon erledigen, weil dann wär sie ja dann wieder kaputt. Deine tolle Struktur. Das ist überhaupt noch das Problem. Diese Software ermutigt einen nicht, den Arsch hochzukriegen. Sie könnte ja mal anfangen, einen zu beschimpfen oder so.
Meinst du jetzt OmniFocus oder?
Ja, alle. Ich meine, irgendwie muss man ja, alle prokrastinieren sich da einen ab. Aber die Applikationen beschimpfen einen nicht ausreichend.
Ja, mein Programm, das mich beschimpft, das ist, mag ich jetzt nur so mittel.
Ja, ist wie mit seinen Eltern dann, ne? Aber irgendwo haben sie einem dann doch ein bisschen Beine gemacht.
Ich möchte auch nicht, dass meine Eltern sünden. Das will man einfach nicht.
Räum auf! Räum deine Festplatte auf! Gut, ich werd mir noch mal dieses Notational Velocity anschauen, aber ich bin unzufrieden mit der Gesamtsituation. Genau. Wir haben es eingangs unterlassen, über diesen Playstation-Hack zu reden. Wollen wir das noch tun?
Über welchen von den beiden denn?
Weiß nicht, beide. Ist das ein Thema für uns? Ich weiß nicht, ich bin da jetzt gerade überhaupt nicht informiert.
Ich bin auch überhaupt nicht informiert. Aber ich weiß nur eins, heute stand ja bei Heise auch irgendwas wieder mit Gesundheitskarte. Und wenn ich mir überlege, was in letzter Zeit so an Daten irgendwie abhanden kommen, ob bei Apple oder bei Sony, oder was die so sammeln und was sie so damit machen, oder man weiß eben nicht, was die damit machen, dann will ich gar nicht wissen, wie groß das Geschrei ist, wenn, sagen wir mal, in fünf Jahren da steht 40 Millionen Kredit-, Quatsch nicht Kreditkarten, 40 Millionen Gesundheitskarten-Daten abhanden gekommen.
Ja, aber was will man machen?
Wie, was will man machen?
Soll die ganze Scheiße an einem Lok bleiben, oder was? Irgendwie muss man es doch in das digitale Zeitalterl überkriegen.
Sollen sie sich was einfallen lassen, aber dass da jeder Hoshy an die Daten ran kann, ich weiß nicht.
Naja, aber bei der Gesundheitskarte ist es ja nicht der Fall. Da sind ja die Daten meines Wissens nach tatsächlich auf der Karte gespeichert und bis auf einen ganz geringen Teil zumindest verschlüsselt.
Oh, lass uns keine Sendung über Gesundheitskarte machen.
Ich glaube auch, ich bin da, wie sagt man, nicht qualifiziert.
Vor ewigen Zeiten haben wir da mal ein Chaos-Radio zu gemacht.
So richtig qualifiziert bin ich auch nicht.
Ich kann mich nur noch erinnern, dass man da auch, also Gesundheitskarte ist auch so ein Thema, wo man hat das Gefühl, man steht irgendwie so ein bisschen im Sturm. Weil das ist da einfach alles nicht toll, wie sie sich das alles ausgedacht haben. Aber ich bin da überhaupt nicht mehr in der Diskussion. Von daher halte ich mich da erstmal raus.
Also ich finde zu diesen ganzen Daten, da müssen wir ein Stück weit jetzt durch. Da ist kein Weg vorbei.
Wir müssen durch die Daten durch.
Wir müssen durch die Daten durch und durch die Daten verloren.
Naja, auf jeden Fall hat sich Sony...
Und wenn wir dann alle unsere Daten verloren haben, dann sind wir komplett frei und können endlich durchatmen.
Sony hat sich auf jeden Fall ordentlich blamiert. Darin sind sie ja nun wirklich gut. Das ist auch echt geil. Da wollen sie dir mit Angriffsmullware auf deinen Rechner, mit diesen Root-Kits, diese ganzen Geschichten, sie verschlüsseln alles und lassen dich irgendwie die Videos nicht sehen bei YouTube. Und immer steht irgendwie Sony, Sony, Sony. Und verhindert die ganze Zeit, aber dann mal den Zugriff auf diese privaten Daten, da dann irgendwie mal den selben Aufwand zu treiben, um das Ganze zu beschützen. Also die Versagen.
Ist aber bei Apple auch so. Also in DRM haben sie am Start hier mit ihrem Fairplay. Und dann, wenn man sich anguckt, was die für Krypto- und Zertifizierungs-Scheiß haben, um so eine App irgendwie in deren Store zu kriegen. Da bist du aber echt einen Tag beschäftigt, wenn du das noch nie gemacht hast. Ich war einen Tag beschäftigt. Aber sonst gehen da so Bugs durch. So, ja, wir haben da mal irgendwie ein Jahr gespeichert, ausversehen. Ist schon ein bisschen komisch.
Ja, aber ist nicht so in der Dimension von 70 Millionen User-Accounts gelegt.
Noch nicht.
Das schafft sonst nur die UNESCO.
Ja, Mo bei mir ist noch...
Wir sind 100 Millionen schon. Zu den 75 Millionen verschwundenen kamen nochmal 25 dazu oder so.
Von so einem zweiten System, ne?
Irgendwie so, ja. Aber mir macht das ja nichts, weil ich hab irgendwie diese Spielkonsolen, das ist nicht so meine Ecke. Hab ich nicht, freundlich.
Das hab ich so mein Ding. Ich bin jetzt auch ein bisschen durch.
Wie, jetzt machst du wieder schlapp?
Ich mach schon ganz schön schlapp, ja.
Dann, was haben wir denn noch hier so auf der Liste?
Wir sind ja schon auch wieder bei zweieinhalb Stunden. Das ist ja, ich mein, letztes Mal haben wir so lang gemacht.
Dann schieb ich jetzt mal was ein, dann kannst du ja schon wieder ein bisschen deinen Rechner aufräumen oder so, parallel. Oder die Liste sortieren.
Ja, schieb mal ein.
Wie in eigener Sache, nein, nicht ganz. Also ich bin ja ja so ein Radiohead-Fan, ja. Und da gab's ja vor, wann war das? Ich glaub Ende Februar konnte man ja so, wie Radiohead das beim letzten Album 2007 schon gemacht hat, konnte man das halt kaufen. Diesmal konnte man sich den Preis nicht selber aussuchen, wie vor dreieinhalb Jahren, sondern musste halt das bezahlen, was da stand. Es waren irgendwie, glaub ich, zwei verschiedene Preise. Eins für MP3s mit weiß ich nicht wie viel Kilobit und einmal ein bisschen ein paar Dollar mehr für lossless Waffdateien. So hab ich geschoppt und zwar gleich hier dieses Fan-Package, wo man jetzt irgendwann im Mai irgendwie das Ding als CD plus Scheiblatte plus irgendwie... Dickes Cover und 500 Schnipsel. Wahrscheinlich ist es ein Puzzle, wo ich irgendwie kriegen soll. Und dann gab's von ein paar Tagen, hab ich mal zufällig wieder geklickt, gab's irgendwie zwei Bonus-Tracks zum Runterladen. Hab ich gemacht, auch wieder Waffdateien. Hab die irgendwie in iTunes reingeschoben, hab die nach Apple Lossless konvertiert, weil ich will's ja ein bisschen kleiner, aber ich hab's gerne in Lossless. Hab ich's auch auf mein iPhone geschoben und guck da so hin. Und dann seh ich, wie groß sind die Dateien. Ich muss noch mal gucken, weil es ist wirklich verdammt groß gewesen. Sind die halt, ich klick ganz schnell, drütt, Mist, das war jetzt schlecht vorbereitet, das hätte ich ja schon vorher machen können. Sind die 77 und 48 Megabyte groß. Also in Apple Lossless halt schon, aber es ist eigentlich immer noch ganz schön groß. So, dann hab ich mal geguckt und siehe da, Radiohead vertreibt seine WAF-Dateien zum Runterladen. Die sind nicht in 16 Bit 44 Kilohertz, sondern die sind schon in 24 Bit 44 Kilohertz. Und der eine Song sogar in 24 Bit und 48 Kilohertz. So verkauft man Musik, da ist der Fan gleich happy. Weil wenn Apple hier irgendwie noch ankommt, die haben eigentlich ziemlich, die sind nicht so billiger als eine CD, richtig? Wenn man alle Songs kauft. Dann sind die auch bei 10 Euro, oder? Naja, so was in dem Dreh. Und was kostet so eine CD? Ja gut, die kostet schon ein ganz bisschen mehr. Aber wenn man das halt bei Apple kauft... Ja, oder irgendwelche anderen CDs. Aber auf jeden Fall kriegst du die halt nur mit 256 Kilobit komprimiert. Und das ist halt eben nicht lossless. Also das ist nicht die gleiche Qualität wie eine CD. Ich will jetzt auch gar nicht diesen Krieg anfangen, ob man das noch hören kann oder nicht. Das ist vielleicht auch nur so eine Psychosache, aber ich finde halt, wenn ich so ein Produkt schon für längere Zeit kaufe, finde ich lossless schon ganz cool. Auch weil man sich dann in Zukunft rippen kann, wie man will, ohne noch mal zusätzlichen Verlust irgendwie sich einzufangen. Und da finde ich den Vorstoß von Radiohead auch gleich, wenn wir schon alles komplett digital machen, gleich mal irgendwie die Bits ein bisschen zu erhöhen, finde ich schon ganz cool.
Also ich hab jetzt hier mal Radiohead-OK-Computer, aber das ist nicht aktuell, ne?
Nee, das ist das Ursprungsalbum.
Das Album kostet bei Amazon 7,99. Kostet bei iTunes 12,99.
Ja guck, und hier bei Amazon als MP3 kostet es 7 Euro.
7 Euro.
Was ist denn aktuelles? Haben die ein aktuelles?
Nein, die machen Selbstvertrieb. Du kriegst das aktuell nicht. Das letzte heißt, wie hieß das? In Rainbows. Das von vor dreieinhalb Jahren. Genau.
Und 2007.
Genau.
Hier gibt es noch eine Best of 2007.
Obwohl, das aktuelle kann es auch schon geben. Das heißt, King of Limbs. Kannst ja mal gucken, ob das da irgendwo ist. Ich hab das Cover bisher noch nicht gesehen, aber. Kannst ja mal eintippen.
Da oben ist es, ganz oben links. King of Limbs.
13,99.
So. Und als MP3, was war das da unten? Ach sorry, ist gebraucht.
Jetzt guck ich mal, was es bei iTunes kostet.
Kriegst du wahrscheinlich gar nicht bei denen.
Doch, muss es inzwischen, naja, weiß nicht.
Doch, doch, da gibt's.
7,99.
Das gesamte Album.
Ja, mit acht Tricks.
Ist relativ groß, das Album leider.
Interessant. Der alte Scheiß ist teurer und der neue Scheiß ist blöd.
Ja, kurze Einführungsaktionen und so.
Hier kriegst du, bei Amazon kriegst du immerhin, da hast du Plaste.
Also das, was ich jetzt gesagt hab, gilt aber auch nur für diese beiden Bonus-Tracks. Das Album, was ich irgendwie da vor zwei Monaten runtergeladen hab, das hatte, glaube ich, keine 24-Bit, sondern das war normal 16-Bit. Kann dann noch mal hier kurz reingucken, aber...
Ja, also ich weiß, dass ich unter Garantie da nicht auch nur die Spur eines Unterschieds raushören werde, glaube ich, zwischen 256-Kilo-Bit-AAC und uncompressed.
Ist schon richtig, aber wenn du dann doch mal für jemanden eine CD brennen willst, dann musst du das ja wieder erst entpacken. Und wenn die dann sich denken, cool, ich hab hier eine CD, ich mach da mal wieder ein P3s draus. Und schon...
Da ist ja noch so ein Legacy-Gerät.
Ja, es gibt noch so Leute. Was soll ich dir noch erzählen? Also uns hat auch Feedback noch erreicht. Das war eine etwas längere Mail. Mit solchen langen Mails tue ich mich immer sehr schwer, weil da muss man sich immer so konzentrieren, die dann irgendwie komplett zu verstehen.
Es geht jetzt um Final Cut Pro X, ne?
Es geht um Final Cut Pro X. Wir haben uns da ja länger zu unterhalten.
Genau, ich hab mir das Video dann doch noch mal mit sehr großer Begeisterung angeguckt.
Und die haben wirklich halb die Bühne gestürmt, oder? Es hat nicht viel gefehlt.
Das war so super, wie der eine Typ so, sie sagen irgendwas vorne auf der Bühne, tosende Applaus, und dann so eb der Applaus ab. Und irgendwann so noch so ein Typ so, der so, Thank you! Und der ganze Saal lacht. Und das war schon relativ am Anfang. Der hat dann auch ein paar Mal mehr gebrüllt.
Ja, aber bisher keine neuere.
Die Barfeuer war umsonst.
Das hat man auch ein bisschen gemerkt. Das hat schon, das war schon ganz cool gemacht.
Ja, also es gab hier so ein paar schöne Anmerkungen zur Soundtrack Pro, da hatten wir uns ja so ein bisschen gefragt, wie relevant das eigentlich ist. Also das Ganze ist von, warte mal, ist hier überhaupt gemerkt? Ach Tim, da hast du ja nicht mal eine Quelle gemerkt hier. Meine Güte. Jetzt muss man noch mal sagen, wer diese Mail geschrieben hat. Dafür haben wir ja Spotlight. Da muss man nicht selber denken. Das ist immer sehr schön. Genau. Schrieb, dass in den USA jede zweite Serie auf Epic Soundtrack Pro gemischt wird.
Das überrascht mich ja sehr.
Ich glaube, das ist jetzt auch keine Statistik, keine exakte, sondern mehr so eine gefühlte Statistik.
Aber gut, ja auch wenn die gefühlt ist, überrascht mich das sehr. Also das ist irgendwie schon krass. Und dann hat er hier irgendwie auch noch ein paar Bilderchen mitgeschickt und so. Also dieses Color, was halt dabei ist, das macht halt irgendwie so komplette Farbgestaltung von Filmproduktionen. Und seine These ist, dass man halt diese spezialisierte Farbsoftware in der Form schon braucht und er vermutet, dass es eben auch Final Cut Pro X so nicht tun können wird. Allein schon so von dem GUI her, wie sich das präsentiert hat. Gut, heißt ja nicht, dass sie nicht das jetzt komplett aufbrechen. Also das könnte ich mir halt auch vorstellen, dass sie einfach das Studio, wie es bisher ist, nehmen und alle relevanten Programme beibehalten und eben einzeln anbieten. Und dann kauft sich halt jeder einfach nur das, was er braucht. Ich hab so den Eindruck, das ist überhaupt jetzt grundsätzlich Apples Weg. Dass sie wieder hingehen zu jeder Applikation für sich und da, wo sie sich Daten und Kollaboration teilen müssen, da baut man das halt einfach ein. Aber gekauft wird halt einzeln und aktualisiert wird halt einzeln und nicht eben dieser Creative Suite Ansatz. Ja, dann meint er, dass Final Cut Pro doch massiv Marktanteile dazu gewonnen habe. Und dass die Avid Cutter so ein bisschen dazu gezwungen werden, auch wenn sie da eigentlich nicht so richtig glücklich mit sind. Als es viele Bugs gibt in dem alten Final Cut Pro, berichtet hier von, vergisst seine Key-Command-Belegung und sei dann doch auch in jüngster Zeit etwas absturzfreudiger gewesen. Na gut, dass your mileage may vary. Andererseits meint er auch, dass irgendwie so durchgesichert sei, dass die Performance von Final Cut Pro X wohl wirklich, wie er sagt, atemberaubend ist. Also, das wundert mich auch nicht. Ich meine, in dem Moment, wo sie auf Lip Dispatch umschalten und wirklich mal ganz konsequent alle Chores nutzen, ich denke, da werden wir noch bei so manchen Programmen sehen, dass da eine enorme Steigerung stattfindet. 4K als Feature gab es wohl auch schon vorher. Und naja, da meint er noch, sie hätten alle so ein bisschen Angst vor der neuen Timeline, dass es nicht genug Kontrolle bietet, über die Details in den einzelnen Frames. Das wird man halt sehen. Ich bin gespannt, bin da wirklich extrem gespannt. Vor allem bin ich mal gespannt, ob es bald mal eine ordentliche Audioschnittlösung gibt auf der Basis. Wir werden es sehen. Dann sind wir noch gebeten worden, aber ich glaube, das machen wir heute nicht, aber ich dachte, ich spreche das mal kurz an. Es war so ein bisschen der Hörerwunsch, dass wir den nicht mal wieder so ein bisschen den Erklärbär machen können und mal so ein Walkthrough durch das macOS 10 Datalsystem machen.
Was haltet denn davon?
Die Struktur der Daten, also der Files oder des Untendrunters.
Was sowohl liegt und was, weißt du? Library, so habe ich das verstanden.
Das System liegt an System und Library und so weiter und dann noch mein Home.
Ich glaube, er hat sich das schon ein bisschen detaillierter vorgestellt.
Der Kernel ist ein Slash.
Ja, aber er gehört ja noch mehr dazu, dieser ganze P-List-Kram und Start-up-Sequenzen und welcher Reihenfolge und Launch-Agents und dieser ganze Fu.
Ehrlich gesagt habe ich da schon lange nicht mehr so wirklich reingeguckt.
Wäre für mich auch mal wieder eine Aktualisierung, aber so grundsätzlich, kann man das schon mal machen. Aber das machen wir nicht heute. Da sind wir wieder ausreichend vorbereitet.
Ja, es wäre böses Rätelraten wieder.
Wahrscheinlich. Ich wollte noch auf was hinweisen, vielleicht habt ihr eine Ahnung. Und zwar, es gibt zur Zeit, McLegion heißt das, gibt es mal wieder so eine Sammelaktion, wo es so viele Apps zum kleinen Preis gibt. Und kostet, da gibt es für 50 Dollar, gibt es das Spring Bundle. McLegion. Legion. Und da ist unter anderem Screenflow dabei, ein sehr, sehr geiles Programm, um Screencast zu machen, was normalerweise schon allein 100 Dollar kostet.
Was kostet das Bundle?
50 Dollar. Da ist Launchbar dabei, da ist Amadeus Pro dabei, was so eine Aufnahmesoftware ist. Der Rest ist jetzt nicht so doll, aber schon allein wegen den drei Apps lohnt sich das bestimmt. Ansonsten sind noch so Sachen dabei wie Printopia. Das ist so eine Software, mit der kann wer mag, sein Mac zu einem IOS-tauglichen Drucker umbauen. Forklift, das ist so ein SFTP-Client. Virus-Barrier, keine Ahnung, ob man das braucht. Antiviren-Software, langsam könnte das interessant werden.
Also, ich stimme dir voll zu. Amadeus, Greenflow und Launchbar.
Na und ich glaube, Data Rescue ist gar nicht so schlecht. Das ist so ein Datalsystem. Also, wenn das Datalsystem gecrasht ist und man trottelt, hat man wieder keinen Backup da, dann kann das unter Umständen noch ein paar Daten retten.
Schon lange nicht mehr passiert, muss ich sagen.
Würde ich mir jetzt nicht kaufen, würde ich keinen 100 Dollar für ausgeben, aber wenn das in so einem 50-Dollar-Bundle mit dabei ist, ist das ganz großartig. Also, für Greenflow, Launchbar und Amadeus, das lohnt sich. Und die würden alleine irgendwie so um die 180 Dollar kosten, wenn man sie so separat kauft. Könnt ihr mal mitnehmen. Ja, Forklift ist so ein... uralt war damals so einer der... so noch quasi vor Transmit einer der hübschen Mac OS X Clients. Also vielleicht so bevor es Transmit für Mac OS X gab, sag ich jetzt mal. Und... ja, ist ein OKer Client, kann man bestimmt eine ganze Menge mitmachen, hat viele Einstellungen, hat jetzt nichts dramatisch Tolles, aber wenn man hin und wieder mal so eine Datei auf irgendeinem FTP oder SFTP Server draufspielen will, dann ist das...
Also im Prinzip so was wie Transmit.
Genau. So halt so ein Client oder wie, was gibt's denn da noch alles? MacFuse? Nee, Mac... Gibt's ja noch auf dem Programm.
Es gibt da so einiges, aber ich bin ja treuer Kunde von Transmit. Also das ist einfach mega solide und funktioniert super. Und das ist auch das Einzige, was du mit SSH Agent umgehen kannst.
Nee, mittlerweile lang nicht mehr. Also da gibt's, was ich noch immer genommen hab, ist... Scheiße, jetzt hab ich einen Namenfall. Früher hab ich ja immer so einen Anarchy Client. Der ist leider irgendwann mal ganz, ganz schlecht geworden. Und heißt jetzt mittlerweile anders, aber der kann auch mit SSH umgehen. Interarchie, genau.
Der kann auch SSH Agent? Kann das jetzt schon lange Dateien haben? Keine Ahnung. Die gibt's auch alle irgendwie noch. Aber ich sag ja auch nur, ich vermisse derzeit nichts bei Transmit.
Nö, Transmit ist okay, sieht hübsch aus.
Ich bin aber auch nicht so ein Power-User.
Wobei, wovon... Also Interarchie hat so ein paar Features, dass du zum Beispiel... Die haben so einen angeblich totalen schnellen Modus, in dem sie dir eigentlich total hacky... Die installieren dir, die spielen dir per SSH ein kleines Perl-Script auf dem Server hoch. Und dann installieren sie da sozusagen ihren eigenen Client und erreichen dadurch wohl eine wesentlich höhere Geschwindigkeit. Und der hat so ein paar Features, dass er dir einfach ein paar Befehle auf dem Server ausführen kann. Also er kann dir ein Tar-File auch schon oben auf dem Server anlegen direkt und dann lädst du noch das Tar-File runter oder sowas. Und das sind so Sachen, die Transmit aus irgendeinem Grund nicht kann. Wobei, brauchen tue ich das eigentlich auch nie. Und Transmit macht in angenehmer Art und Weise mit einem guten Aussehen das, was ich haben möchte. Insofern. Aber wer noch keinen Transmit hat, wird mit Forklift bestimmt auch glücklich werden.
Ich hab jetzt noch mal kurz was einschieben. Also bei so alten Monster-Programmen sind, die es schon seit ewigen Zeiten so gibt auf dem Markt, so wie Fetch und Transmit und so und Interarky, gibt's eigentlich coole Terminal-Programme auf dem Mac. Also ich meine jetzt nicht so Terminal für SSH, sondern so, wo man halt eine Serie-Rele drüber macht, so VT-102-Terminals oder sowas. Ja schon, aber ich will halt keinen PowerPC-Emulator mehr auf meinem Rechner haben und Zetterm ist auch schon ein bisschen angegraut halt. Gibt's irgendwie das im modernen?
Hab ich auch schon mal gesucht und es ist erstaunlich, dass das gar nicht gibt, ne?
Ja.
Kriegt man das nicht? Gibt's doch bestimmt irgendwie so ein mitgeliefertes BSD-App dazu, mit dem man eine serielle Verbindung aufmacht, das dann ein Terminal hat?
C-U heißt das oder C-U. Das ist aber total, das kann eigentlich fast nix so, also nicht nur fast, also es kann nix. Und dann, man kann das noch mit dem Kommando Screen machen, Screen, denn das die serielle, das Device halt angeben und dahinter die Bautrate, aber es ist auch alles irgendwie nicht so das Gelbe vom Ei. Und da ich hier mit Atmils und mit Debug- serielle oft irgendwie zusammen arbeite, wollte ich mal wissen, ob es irgendwie noch ein cooles Terminal-Programm ist. Ja, sowas wie Term auf dem Amiga, also das Monster aller Terminal-Programme, die Mutter aller Terminal-Programme, wo auch noch irgendwie X und Y und Z-Mode im Support drin ist und was weiß ich nicht alles, also so einfach alles.
Das ist der Grund, warum ich bisher, ich hab es bis heute nicht übers Herz gebracht, Z-Term wegzuschmeißen. Ich glaube, ich hab das unter Mac OS X wirklich noch nie verwendet.
Ich hab's auch bis vor einer Weile noch benutzt, aber jetzt auch mit, ich hab jetzt keinen PowerPC-Emulator mehr hier installiert, weil ich dachte, ich spar mir das jetzt mal, Zeiten sind wirklich vorbei so langsam. Also wenn nur Z-Term der letzte Grund ist, dann hätte ich gerne auch dafür langsam mal ein Update. Ja, das ist da auch alles nix.
Naja, ich mein, das hat zumindest diese Funktionalitäten. Das ist halt so Text-Gui sozusagen.
Das ist ein Schorn.
Baut sich alles da auf, aber das scheint dir zumindest erst mal weiterhelfen zu können. Also das ist auf jeden Fall besser als CU.
Auf jeden Fall. Wie gesagt, zurzeit benutze ich halt einfach Screen.
Also ich hab jetzt mal bei Google Z-Term Alternative eingegeben und der hat mir Go Serial empfohlen, was es immerhin in der Intel-Version gibt. In einem Wort.
Ich hoffe, die sind auch Go Serias gegangen.
Ist in der Version 03 irgendwas.
Schon wieder.
Beta, RC2.
Ja, aber wenn's... Also ich hab's jetzt, ich seh hier nur Screenshots.
Ich find hier nur George Clooney to Go Serial Killer Hunting.
F-U-R-R Soft. Fettige, soft und fällig.
Weiches Fell. Go Serial.app Aha, das sieht doch richtig nach was aus hier. Andreas Meyer. Go Serial 03.
Gewinnt jetzt keinen Preis, was Usern der Festgestaltung betrifft, aber sieht zumindest schon mal aus, als hättest du den richtigen...
Schlechter als Zetterm kann's ja da gar nicht sein. Wobei Zetterm, ich meine, wie alt ist dieses Programm? Der kam extra noch mal aus dem Grab gestiegen, um das für PowerPC klar zu machen. Ich meine, seit wann gibt's das schon?
Der hat das noch mal für Mac OS X angepasst seit ewig.
Der hat das schon damals für PowerPC angepasst. Das ist eigentlich 68K Software.
Stimmt, ja, das war ja noch...
Das Ding ist sowas von alt. Die Hälfte unserer Hörer gab's noch gar nicht. Wollen wir mal rausfinden, von wann Zetterm wirklich ist? Steht wahrscheinlich gar nicht da.
Zetterm, das war... Oh Gott, was war ein Zetterm? Das war dieses Z-Mode im Übertragungsprotokoll, was er ja konnte. Ich weiß noch, dass man da bei diesen Mailboxen immer angeben könnte, ob man X-Modem, Y-Modem oder Z-Modem machen wollte. Zetterm war das einzige, was einen Progress bar hatte, bild ich mir ein.
Zetterm war nur ein Protokoll. Also X-Modem und Y-Modem, das waren halt Protokolle, die die beiden Gegenseiten machen, um eben Dateitransfer zu machen, damit du eben so ein Minimum an Kontrollflow, Packetflow und eben Vertrauenssicherheit hast. Ich weiß jetzt die Details nicht mehr, sonst genau. Ich glaube, Z-Modem war das erste, was so mit CheXum gearbeitet hat. Und 1994, 19. April 1994, mit anderen Worten, das ist jetzt...
17 Jahre. Aber ich sehe gerade erst nochmal aus dem Grab gestiegen, jetzt zum dritten Mal schon, das hat nicht mal Jesus geschafft. Und er will noch ein New-Universal-Bild machen.
Ach echt?
Also Mai 2008, er braucht mal eine Weile. Oder gibt es die sogar schon? 2002, Public Beta auf Version 1.1?
Genau, Z-Modem war ein bisschen schneller.
Z-Modem war so shit, das ist cool, ich kenn mich da auch. Also bei X-Modem, also für die Leute, die nicht wissen, was das ist.
Wir sollten mal erklären, worüber wir jetzt eigentlich gerade reden.
Also früher gab es Mailboxen.
Vor allem Terminal ist nämlich so ein Begriff, den muss man echt mal ein bisschen aufstehen. So jetzt hier, Papa erzählt vom Krieg.
Genau, pass auf, damals, da gab es Mailboxen, da hat man angerufen mit einem Modem, da konnte man googeln, was das ist. Und da gab es noch kein Internet, hast dich in so eine Mailbox eingewählt und du konntest eigentlich, da gab es nichts mit, du konntest nichts parallel machen, sondern du hast immer eine bestimmte Sache gemacht. Also entweder hast du dich in so einem Forum durchgeklickt oder du hast...
Was heißt geklickt? Man hat die Tasten, man hat so ein virtuelles...
Mit den Cursor-Tasten. Mäuse gab es schon auch, aber eigentlich, also es war alles Text gesteuert. Oder man hat am Forum gelesen oder Newsbeiträge gelesen oder man konnte halt in den Download-Bereich gehen und konnte Files runterladen. So, da das aber alles mehr oder weniger Text basiert war, mussten die sich halt überlegen, wie die von dieser Mailbox irgendwie Daten zu deiner Seite rüber gekriegt haben. Und da wurde halt zum Beispiel X, Y und Z Modem benutzt. Und zwar in der Reihenfolge. Erst gab es X Modem. Das heißt, du hast drüben den Download gestartet, dann haben die so eine Sequenz geschickt und dann hat dein Terminal-Programm gewusst, dass da jetzt ein X Modem startet und hat auf Empfang geschaltet und dann sind die Daten reingeflohen gekommen. Und bei X Modem glaube ich in 256 Byte-Blöcken, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere. Oder vielleicht sogar schon 1 Kilo Byte-Blöcken. Und die hatten glaube ich auch eine Check-Summe. Und da musstest du aber immer auf die Antwort gewartet werden. Und dann wurde erst der nächste Block geschickt. Bei Y Modem war es dann ein bisschen besser. Ist aber eigentlich egal, es war nicht viel besser. So und bei Z Modem war es so, die konnten erstens ihre Blöcke bis auf 8 Kilobyte vergrößern. Und zweitens haben die immer Blöcke geschickt. Und du hast irgendwann gesagt, ob die nun okay waren oder nicht. Das heißt, das Z Modem musste dadurch nicht warten, ob die nun okay waren oder nicht. Genau, Sliding Windows. So wie man das bei TCP IP jetzt auch schon hat. Und dadurch war Z Modem einfach the shit. Also es war einfach exakt so schnell, wie deine Modem-Verbindung gerade schnell war. Das heißt, wenn du 14.400 Kilo bist...
Leitungsgeschwindigkeit.
Genau, wenn du 14.400 Kilobit hattest, dann hast du exakt einen Download gehabt mit 1610 Bytes die Sekunde. Das müsst ihr euch jetzt mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen, was man damals so für Speed hatte.
Ich kann mich noch daran erinnern, als ich mal wirklich vor Begeisterung ausgerastet bin, dass ich über ein Kilobyte pro Sekunde hatte.
Das war der Augenblick, wo du von deinem 9600er Modem auf einen 144er gewechselt hast.
Ne, mit einem neuen 6er Modem konnte man unter ganz idealen Bedingungen auch mehr.
1110 oder was war das? Naja, ich erinnere mich.
Aber so gute Leitung hatten wir damals im Osten, nicht? Das war wirklich über ein Kilobyte.
Das war wuhuuu!
Naja, ich erinnere mich auch noch. Jedenfalls deswegen ist Z-Modem ganz cool. Weil man auch mit seinem Terminal-Programm sich zum Beispiel in der Uni eingewählt hat. Da hat man dann wirklich eine Shell bekommen. Das, was wir heute aus dem aktuellen Terminal-Programm kennen, dass man einen SSH öffnen kann, auch wenn es das wahrscheinlich damals noch nicht so richtig gegeben hat. Jedenfalls konnte man da ja auch Dateien übertragen. Und weil es aber keine Mailbox war, sondern halt irgendeine Solariskiste oder sowas, gab es dort die Kommandos SZ und RZ. Und das war halt Send Z-Modem. Da konntest du halt SZ irgendwie, Dateiname, sagen. Und dann wurde dieser, auf deren Seite sozusagen gesehen, ein Upload gestartet. Und bei dir, dein Terminal hat an dem, also das Terminal-Programm hat an dem Beisequenz wieder erkannt, dass jetzt ein Z-Modem startet und hat das Ding eingesaugt. Und danach ging es dann halt irgendwie weiter. Und dieses, also wir werden mal sehen, dass wirklich die Mutter aller Terminal-Programme sehen will, der sollte sich dieses Term auf dem Amiga angucken. Das war wirklich, das konnte wirklich alles. Also es gab nichts, was es nicht konnte.
Damals, als Xyxl noch cool war, könnt ihr euch auch noch dran erinnern?
Klar, ich hab immer noch mein 1496 zu Hause.
Ich hab nie die Kohle gehabt.
Ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, da gab's keinen Xyxl.
Also ich hatte nie die Kohle für so ein Xyxl-Mode.
Das war 21D, aber jetzt sind wir wirklich im Opa-Modus.
Ich hab neulich mal einen Xyxl-DSL-WLAN-Router gesehen. Das ist so billige Scheiße, das will man nicht mehr haben. Also das erste, was ich mir selber gekauft hab, das war schon 19.2, das war so dieser etwas schneller als 14.4 Standard, 19.2 Turbo, oder wie das hieß.
Das Turbo war aber schon wieder was Spezielles. Das war kein richtiger Standard.
Das war kein Standard, da gab's nun ganz, ganz wenige, das konnte ich nicht.
Hier meint einer, Z-Term ist von 86.
Ja, hab ich auch gelesen, aber bisher noch keine Bestätigung. Wikipedia meint 92.
Na ja, 92 ist aber auch schon verdammt alt. Ja, jedenfalls, ich hätte gerne ein geiles Terminal-Programm.
Könnt ihr euch noch an First Class erinnern? Hatte da jemand von euch so einen Account für? Das war so was, damit konnte man sich, da konnte man nämlich schön rumklicken und so per Drag & Drop und Doppelklick und so richtig auf dem Nick mit Fans da und so.
Das waren so diese ersten, so Anfang der 90er Jahre, die erste Hälfte der 90er Jahre, als sie alle versucht haben, ihre eigenen Netzwerke hochzuziehen. Und First Class war so eins dieser Dinger, als auch Apple mit E-World rum experimentiert hat und diese ganzen Geschichten.
Na, First Class, konntest du dir selber kaufen. Du konntest einen First Class-Server kaufen, da gab es auch in Berlin so ein paar Mailboxen von, die das hatten, die haben alle Geld gekostet. Und ich hab mal ein Fido, nicht ein Fido Client geschrieben, sondern was ich, was ich überleg grad, was das App gekonnt hab, was ich da geschrieben habe, das Programm. Programm, damals hieß das aber nicht App. Ich hab für, ähm, es gab für Fido, hat also jemand von euch ein Fido-Account? Schade. Weil da gab's, ähm, der Client, um so News und so was da mitzulesen, der hieß glaub ich Alice, kann das sein? Erinnert sich da noch jemand dran?
Nie Fido gemacht.
Fido war super. Fido war echt toll. Also Alice war so ein Client, der konnte diverse Protokolle, unter anderem hier auch Fido. Und er brauchte dafür so ein Helferprogramm. Den Namen hab ich vergessen. Das war dann so ein, das hat sich eingewählt, hat alle Mails, die man bekommen hat, runtergeladen auf den eigenen Rechner, hat alle Mails, die man verschicken wollte, hochgeschickt und hat dann so alle Groups, die man abonniert hatte, runtergeladen. Man konnte sagen, ruf an, handle ab, was du zu erledigen hast und leg sofort wieder auf. Fido war sehr stark darauf optimiert, die Leitung so kurz wie möglich zu blockieren.
Weil es ja Geld gekostet hat.
Und weil auch in einigen Ländern eine besetzte Leitung Geld gekostet hat. Das war immer das Argument. Aber es ist natürlich auch so gut, wenn man die Leitung so kurz wie möglich blockiert. Darum hab ich mal für Fido so ein Programm geschrieben, wo man Datei nahm, wenn man so irgendwo in Mainz war, eine Mailbox, bei der man jetzt irgendeine Datei runterladen wollte. Und die konnte man sich auch per Fido-Protokoll runterladen. Dann hat man nämlich den Datei-Namen eingegeben. Dann hatte er dann eine Verbindung, gab so ein Fido-Telefonbuch quasi für ganz Deutschland, wo dann alle Telefonnummer von jeder Mailbox drauf stand. Hatte sich aus dieser Mailbox, aus diesem Telefonbuch die Telefonnummer rausgesucht, hat dann da angerufen, hat Bescheid gesagt, hey, gib mir mal diese Datei und hat die runtergeladen und dann ist die bei dir auf deinem Mac gewesen. War ich stolz wie Bolle drauf, hieß Fido Parcel Service so ein bisschen eine Anlehnung an UPS. Ach ja, das war noch Zeit, da hab ich Pascal geschrieben.
Opa erzählt vom Krieg. Haben wir noch mehr Zeug, um unsere jungen Hörer zu langweiligen? Die denken sich jetzt wahrscheinlich wieder, wir haben echt einen Meise. Wartet mal, in 20 Jahren erzählt ihr genau den gleichen Scheiß. Wusstest du, damals noch Internet Explorer 9?
Wir wären ja froh, wenn wir mehr als 140 Zeichen gehabt hätten.
Wir hatten ja nichts. 16 Megabit Internetanschluss.
Nix hatten wir.
Wir hatten ja noch Daten, die uns wegkommen konnten.
Hier geht gerade ein schöner Link. BBS-Documentary, da gibt es diese schöne Video-Dokumentation der alten Zeiten, so mit den ganzen Modem-Mailbox-BBS-Zeiten. Das ist cool, bbsdocumentary.com. Das sollte man sich wirklich mal anschauen. So langweilig das jetzt vielleicht auch für manche von euch jetzt hier sich anhören mag, es lohnt sich sehr, sich mal so ein bisschen mit den Realitäten der 80er-Jahre vertraut zu machen. Das hat einfach das Potenzial für viel Aha, wo man so Sachen wiederfindet und die Erklärung vor allem dafür, die heute auch immer wieder noch so vor das Gesicht schlagen. Gerade, wenn es um serielle Schnittstellen geht und was die alles so für merkwürdige Konfigurationen haben wollen. 8 in 1, Mobile Max 8 in 1.
8 in 1, das war irgendwie 8 Datenbits, 1 Stoppbit oder ein Parity-Bit, ne?
No Parity.
Und ich benutze das immer noch, weil diese Artmils hält, da musst du genau das so einstellen.
Ja, das ist ein ganzer Embedded-Kram, da kommt man nämlich dann genau wieder hin.
Da hab ich mir halt jetzt gerade voll toll, wenn wir schon mal dabei sind, so einen kleinen Adapter geholt von TTL-Serial nach Bluetooth, damit ich irgendwie nicht mehr so ein USB-Kabel noch brauche, sondern das hat gleich so ein Bluetooth-Stein mit drauf, stecke ich irgendwie auf meinen Atmel drauf und dann habe ich hier die Serielle, das ist voll toll.
Ah, dann kannst du über die Serielle von deinem Mac das machen. Also über die Bluetooth-Serielle deines Macs.
Bluetooth, die peeren sich und dann habe ich hier in meinem Slash-Dev, wenn wir schon bei der Feilstruktur sind, habe ich dann da halt das Serial-Device und kann dann halt eben mit Screen das Serial-Device öffnen und habe dann den Output von meinem Atmel. Gibt es bei Sparkfun. Da gibt es immer sehr viel Arduino- und Atmel-Zeugs und all so Bastel-Zeugs.
Ich finde jetzt leider nicht das schöne Modem, was ich mal hatte. 84.
Gott, das waren noch Zeiten.
Da konnte man noch mit Fingerfertigkeit kostenlos telefonieren. Nee, nee, es ging noch ein bisschen einfacher in Deutschland. Also es gab so eine eingebaute Backdoor im Telefonnetz für Telekom-Mitarbeiter. Wenn die dir eine neue Leitung eingerichtet haben. Post-Mitarbeiter.
Ach so, dann gab es nur diesen Rückruf.
Nee, noch einfacher. Die hatten so ein Spezialtelefon, die hatten so eine W-Scheibe, auf der sich nicht nur 10, sondern 11 Ziffern befanden. Also du kannst nicht nur noch eine 0...
Weil ja, dass halt Puls vorhanden war.
Genau.
Und den Puls hat man einfach ein bisschen länger gelassen.
Er wird einfach noch einmal mehr geknackt. Also wenn du so die W-Scheibe gezogen hast, lässt sie dann los, so lang wie du sie eben reingezogen hast, zieht sie wieder zurück und bei jeder Ziffern, der sie vorbeikommt, macht sie halt einmal Klack. Also als würde man einfach mal kurz schalten, oder? Den höher auflegen und wieder abnehmen. Statt der Null für die vollständige, als Escape-Zeichen, wählst du quasi eine 11. Also wenn du nicht 030 lalalala die Nummer wählst, sondern 1130, genau, also nicht 10 mal tackern, sondern 11 mal tackern, dann war es halt kostenlos. Und das ging aber universell, generell mit jeder Telefonnummer. Das heißt, mindestens deutschlandweit. Was ja nicht unerheblich war, weil damals Ferngespräche teuer. Das heißt, man konnte sich wirklich hinsetzen an sein Telefon und dann so tatat mit dem Finger einfach 11 mal hintereinander auf die Auflegentaste draufdrücken. Und wenn du die erste geschafft hast, kannst du einfach normal weiterwählen und dann kannst du kostenlos telefonieren. Weiß ich noch sehr gut. Das ging, wurde dann auch irgendwann abgeschaltet. Das hat sich ein bisschen rumgesprochen. Aber so echt wieder so ein klassisches Security-Problem.
Was dann halt auch später ging, ist, dass es so eine Nummer gab, die hast du angerufen und dann wurdest du von der automatisch irgendwie zurückgerufen. Das war wahrscheinlich dann die Ablösung von dem, was du beschrieben hast.
Das kann sein, ja.
Ja, da gab es doch massenhaft. Ich habe so ein ganzes Verzeichnis gehabt mit kostenlosen Rufnummern, die man dann auch unter irgendwelchen Umständen, ich bin nie dahinter gekommen, ich war viel zu jung und zu naiv, aber mich irgendwie mal abendlang in irgendwelche kostenlosen Mailboxen reinwählen. Da stand da irgendwas von AT&T und anderen Dingen, die ich nicht verstanden habe.
Wir können ja auch mal irgendwann das Serialport erklären, das machen wir heute aber auch nicht mehr. Ich sehe gerade im Chat irgendwie die ganzen Begriffe rattern durch, RTS, TTS, DTRD.
Da hätte ich einen Vorschlag, du machst einfach mal, achso, du hast schon eine Sendung über Mikrocontroller und so, ne?
Ich soll noch eine über die V24 machen?
Ach, Menschenskinder, wegen den Location-Datens habe ich komplett vergessen. Und zwar der Michael Kreil, den ich neulich mal kennengelernt habe, der die Location-Daten von Malte Spitz so schön aufgereitet hat für Zeit Online. Der hat jetzt ein Projekt gestartet mit ein paar anderen Leuten zusammen. Und zwar, wo man seine Consolidated DB spenden kann für einen guten Zweck. Nämlich um eine freie Datenbank aufzubauen mit allen GSM, möglichst vielen GSM- und WLAN-Hotspots in Europa oder weltweit. Wo man dann einfach diese Datei hochladen kann und dann wäre eine große Datenbank eingestragen. Dann hat man ja eine relativ aktuelle Datenbank aller GSM- und WLAN-Hotspots in der Umgebung. Und die wollen das damit aufbauen. crowdflow.org war das, ne?
Ich weiß es gerade nicht.
Nicht.
crowdflow.net crowdflow.net Naja, genau.
Also schnell eure Daten aufspenden.
Bevor ihr auf 433 aktualisiert.
Wenn ihr das überhaupt wollt.
Wo sind denn jetzt die fertigen Maps? Ist das nur das, was man da jetzt gerade sieht?
Im Blog sind da noch einige von Deutschland. Von Deutschland sind es besonders viele. Deutschland ist aber großzügig gedacht.
First Glimpse of World Wide Cell Phone Coverage. 700 Logs haben sie. Naja, jemand hat halt einfach mal begonnen, diese ganzen Consolidate DB zusammenzutragen und genau dasselbe zu tun, was Apple damit auch macht.
Ja, man kann denen diese File checken.
Genau, und dann einfach mal zu gucken, wo sind denn die Cell Tower und wo sind denn die VLAN Exist Points? Crowdflow heißt es halt.
Finde ich eine tolle Idee.
Ja, ob da jetzt so substanziell was vorauskommt, dann merkt man, dass es in Deutschland gestartet ist. Da ist das Ziel am meisten los. Ist echt erstaunlich.
Guck mal, die Berliner. Wi-Fi-Stations sehen doch gar nicht schlecht aus. Außer, dass sie da einen merkwürdigen Knick drin haben.
Ja, schöne Heatmaps.
Ja, der kann sowas aus.
Das hättet er mal vorhin sagen müssen, als ich meine Daten noch hatte. Jetzt sind sie ja schon weg. Ja, hab ich schon gebackupt.
Ja, aber du hast doch noch einen Backup.
Hast du einen Backup von meinem Backup, meinste? Da ist ja ein Backup hier und von hier das Backup.
Ich weiß nicht, gibt es auch ein älteres Backup?
Ja, zu Hause auf dem Server kann ich mal gucken. Time Machine sogar.
Menschenskinder.
Dann ist doch eigentlich alles in Ordnung. So, wollen wir uns jetzt hier noch weiterquälen? Oder wollen wir einfach mal ein bisschen Schluss machen?
Lass uns mal ein bisschen Schluss machen für heute.
Wir haben fertig, ich denke auch. Mehr ist heute nicht drin, aber wir waren immerhin pünktlich. Und wir hoffen natürlich, nächstes Mal auch wieder mit einem frischen Huckel an den Start zu kommen hier. Nächstes Mal hast du keine Ausrede. Bis dahin passieren dann auch irgendwelche wichtigen Sachen. Habt ihr irgendwelche Termine? Nichts McIntosh-related, was ich jetzt gerade so sehe.
Naja, doch.
Was denn?
Naja, nächste Woche wird Line released.
Nächste Woche?
Was macht dich da so sicher? Du behauptest es jetzt einfach mal. Aber es gibt jetzt wenig Indizien, die dafür sprechen, dass dem so ist, oder? Ich glaube, das kommt erst zur WWDC.
Die war da Anfang Juni schon, ne?
Das stimmt.
Oh, richtig, klar. Jetzt wo du es sagst. Die WWDC ist in der Tat 6. Juni in einem Monat. Ja, ich denke, die Zeit werden sie sich noch lassen.
Ja, das glaube ich.
Also da ist jetzt wenig zu gewinnen. Also ich vermute mal, da werden wir dann auch noch in der nächsten und vielleicht auch noch in der übernächsten Sendung noch im Dunkeln tappen, was denn nun das große, besondere, geheime Feature ist, was sie uns bisher noch nicht gezeigt haben.
Ja, aber das haben sie bei SnowLab auch schon gemacht und dann war da auch genau nichts. Also meistens ist das immer so nichts Großes mehr.
Ich glaube daran. I want to believe, da ist noch irgendwas drin. Wenn sogar Sinks jetzt schon ankündigt, dass sie vielleicht irgendwann mal Cloudsyncing haben, was soll noch passieren? Also ist doch jetzt wirklich...
Also was ich gesehen habe, ich hab ja versucht, einfach mal illegalerweise, so, verklagt mich doch, zu installieren, den Preview 2. Hat alles nicht funktioniert, weil das irgendwie nicht ging. Ich weiß nicht warum, genau. Hatt ich dann auch keinen Bock, weil es noch öfter zu probieren. Und Festplatten waren mir alles viel zu langsam und ich hab nicht noch eine zweite SSD. Jedenfalls fragt der schon beim Anfang, beim Installieren, ob man sein Zeug irgendwie... ob man es entkrypten will. Genau, nicht kompamieren, entkrypten. Mhm, das war beim ersten nicht so. Ich würde es erstmal keinem empfehlen, weil wenn dann nach dem Booten, nämlich Spotlight und das Encryption im Hintergrund läuft, dann geht da auch wirklich erst mal überhaupt gar nichts. Und wenn man dann noch so wie ich seine Testfestplatte per USB angeschlossen hat, dann geht da überhaupt wirklich nichts mehr. Und dann müsste man das Ding erstmal wirklich stundenlang grödeln lassen, bis es irgendwie fertig ist. Aber grundsätzlich ist es natürlich eine coole Sache, dass Apple doch ein bisschen an meine Daten denkt, wie auch immer, ob es dann auch sicher ist aus deren Sicht.
Ja, deine Daten sind Apple eine Menge wert.
Vor allem, was mir durch den Kopf gegangen ist, also abgesehen davon, dass dieses Krypto-Feature nett ist, dass man seine Daten verschlüsselt hat, ist es ja auch mittlerweile zwingend nötig mit den SSDs, weil du ja sonst einfach deine Platten nicht mehr so richtig leer kriegst. So eine Platte, die irgendwie die ganze Zeit, wo du überhaupt keine Kontrolle mehr darüber hast, wo das Bit so richtig hingeht, und die ganze Zeit solche Vermeidungsstrategien.
Weil die das ummappingen machen. Aber es ist eigentlich gar nicht schlimm, weil die ganzen neuen SSDs, die haben sowieso intern, wird bei denen alles immer verschlüsselt. So wie beim iPhone 4 könnte man das ein bisschen so sehen. Und wenn man da so einen Quick-Erase macht, also wirklich die gesamte Platte, dann wird einfach dieser Schlüssel weggeschmissen und sie setzt einen neuen rein.
Ach echt, die haben schon Krypto on Board.
Mhm, musst du mal lesen hier bei dieser Intel 320 Series, die jetzt gerade auch rauskam, einen Monat nach der meine rauskam, die hat das schon. Und einige andere wohl auch. Weil das war wirklich ein Problem, dass man halt nicht zuverlässig irgendwie Zeug löschen kann. Und für Firmen ist das ja schon wichtig.
Auch.
Das ist ja cool.
Ja, sonst ist hier nämlich hier... Dump-Diving hieß das ja, ne?
Und heißt das dann auch, ich meine, man benutzt das nur zum Löschen? Da könnte man ja genauso gut auch in allen Interfaces das einfach benutzen.
Also es wird erstmal von alleine gesetzt. Man kann aber auch... Das ist halt so ein... Im BIOS das Passwort dafür setzen. Das BIOS muss da wahrscheinlich so ein SATA-Command schicken. Das hab ich nicht ganz genau verstanden, weil es gibt's ja wieder auf dem Mac irgendwie alles nicht so richtig. Aber so ein PC kann das wohl, glaube ich, nehme ich mal an.
BIOS.
Und dann kannst du da dein Passwort selber setzen und wenn es halt wieder umsetzt oder die Platte in einen anderen Rechner einbauen, dann geht es halt erstmal nicht. Irgendwie so. is coming. Auf jeden Fall.
Naja, weil diese Sandy Bridge Dinge haben jetzt auch Bild in Krypto Support, sodass es ordentlich und schnell geht. Und dann kostet das auch nichts mehr.
Jetzt guck ich mal unsere nächsten Daten an. Also 65 ist am 68, 66 ist am 1. Juni. Dann ist die WWDC. Und dann haben wir genau am 8. Nee, 15 am 15. Also wenn die ganze WWDC vorbei ist und unsere nächste Sendung, da müssten wir ja schon alles gut wiedergekeut haben. Naja.
Und auf iOS 5 abgedatet haben.
Das wird da glaube ich noch nicht kommen. Aber sie werden es wahrscheinlich previewen. Sie werden sagen, was kommt.
Genau, das werden die ersten Beta Versionen rumgehen. Man wird überlegen, muss ich mein Ah, soll ich mein iPhone jetzt schon der Gefahr aussetzen mit iOS 5 oder die tollen neuen Features schon freu zu haben.
Jetzt noch gefährlicher.
Ah, ich sehs da schon.
Ok, bevor wir Gefahr laufen, dass diese Sendung noch länger wird. Ist nämlich schon wieder jetzt schon viel zu lang. Ich sag mal, machen wir jetzt mal ein bisschen Schluss, wa?
So ein bisschen Schluss.
Machen wir so ein bisschen Schluss. Kroffos hat euch gefallen. Leute, bis später.
Wir sehen uns in zwei Wochen wieder da. Genau.
Tschüssi! Wink, wink.
Danke fürs Kommen und wir sehen uns bald! Tschüss!